Die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.
Ich bin in Düsseldorf geboren, wohne aber leider in Leichlingen und bin schon immer hingefallen. Ich bin schon über 40 Jahre Fortuna-Fan. Ich war in der Fertigliga, genauso auf Akka, in Bad Thonlew und und und, heute bin ich auch in Fortuna, dass wir aufsteigen. Hurra, hurra, die Fortuna ist da. Hier regiert einer, Fortuna ist sonst keiner. Und an allen Grüßen, die mich kennen.
Alles zur 2.
Bundesliga. Ihr habt richtig gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es geht mal wieder über die 2. Liga im Rasenfunk. Zum zweiten Mal gibt es einen Rasenfunk Royal XS, wie ich es nenne, in Anlehnung an die Mammut-Sendung zur 1. Liga, die dann übrigens am morgigen Pfingstsonntag erscheinen wird. Aber heute wollen wir uns mit der 2. Liga befassen und selten war ich mehr auf Experten angewiesen als bei diesem Thema. Ich gebe es zu, mein 2. Liga-Konsum hält sich in engen Grenzen, ich muss mich dann doch eher auf die 1. Liga konzentrieren und deshalb bin ich froh, dass ich hier drei Experten um mich versammelt habe, die ich euch gerne hier einmal vorstelle. Zum einen Sebastian Zobel, Journalist und FCK-Experte beim SWR. Servus, Sebastian. Sehr schön, dass das geklappt hat. Wir haben eine gemeinsame Vergangenheit bei Spox, die wollen wir jetzt hier nicht auch nochmal aufarbeiten. Aber schön, dass der Kontakt hier bis in den Rasenfunk gehalten hat. So soll es doch sein. Dunkel? Ja, naja. Dunkel für uns beide, glaube ich. Außerdem mit dabei, freut mich auch sehr, dass wir mal wieder hier sprechen können. Stefan Helmer von Clubfans United, die auch einen eigenen Podcast haben, den ihr hoffentlich hin und wieder hört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Servus, Stefan. Schön, dass das geklappt hat. Und mit seiner Premiere im Rasenfunk eingefordert von Menschenmassen mit brennenden Missgabeln in der Hand. Schon seit ganz, ganz langem. Enzo, der LL Curly von 390. Servus, Enzo. Ja, da hättest du nicht mehr mit gerechnet. Was? Aber was kann ich denn dafür, wenn dein Verein einfach Zweitklassik ist, also der VfB-Studio? Lasst uns nicht mit irgendwelchen Spitzen aufhalten. Wir wollen so ein bisschen die Enterwelle durchgehen und ihr müsst mir dann erklären, was das für eine Zweitligasaison war. Vielleicht fangen wir ein bisschen allgemeiner erstmal an. Sebastian, was war es denn für dich als erfahrenen Zweitligisten? Sorry. Was war denn das für eine Zweitligasaison? Die Vorzeichen waren schon etwas besonders, dadurch, dass mit Stuttgart und Hannover zwei Vereine abgestiegen sind, die vielleicht auch selber so gar nicht damit gerechnet hatten. Jetzt so in der Retrospektive, hat man das auch gemerkt?
Bisschen heiler in Heidenheim hat auch kein Party gemacht.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Das ist in Heidenheim wahrscheinlich schwierig. Ja gut, aber so fügt sich eins zum anderen. Frank Schmidt, der Trainer, auf jeden Fall unheimlich interessante Person, hat ja schon in sehr, sehr jungen Jahren die Mannschaft, ich glaube, sogar noch als Spielertrainer übernommen. Und seitdem ist er da, kann man in der bekannten Trainer-Doku Profis, heißt sie, glaube ich, nachschauen. Ach nee, Trainer.
Auch interessant, was aus anderen Trainer geworden ist. Also hier der andere Schmidt, der recht unsympathisch rüberkam. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was aus dem jetzt geworden ist.
Ich glaube, der hat irgendwo jetzt bei einem bekannten Club einen neuen Job bekommen. Wer hat den denn geholt? Hab ich letztens ausgelesen. Müssen wir mal googeln, wo er da hängen ist.
Nein, aber interessant ist auch, der ist seit vielen, vielen Jahren dabei. Immer recht erfolgreich mit seiner Mannschaft. Aus dem Stuttgarter Unfalls hast du immer wieder mal gehört, den hätten wir gerne. Aber so richtig auf irgendwelche Listen landet der nie, oder?
Jein, ich hab's jetzt im Zuge der Mainz-Debatte gehört, aber nur von Journalisten, die nicht so nah dran waren. Denn alle anderen haben gleich gesagt, das wird Sandro Schwarz machen.
Die Mainze sind ja auch so ein Verein, die bilden ihre Trainer selber aus.
In Nürnberg war der letztes Jahr auch im Gespräch, in der Verlosung, nachdem René Weiler zuanderlich gegangen ist.
Ja, aber ich frag mich, sind die denn, also klar, das eine ist, sind die auf der Liste, weil man den gerne hätten, das andere ist, hast du eine realistische, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der weg will.
Ich glaub, der will nicht unbedingt weg, und der würde auch, glaub ich, was kosten. Und für mich ist aber auch die Frage, ob er woanders als in Heidenheim auch funktionieren wird. Na, das weiß man immer nicht.
Das hast du ja immer, du hast ja immer gerade Jola in der Diskussion gehabt.
Das ist auch der erste Name gewesen, an den ich gedacht hätte, wie er irgendwie über den Weg geht.
Ja, aber Schmidt war jetzt auch ein Trainer, der ist jetzt ja schon ewig in Heidenheim. Ich weiß nicht, ist halt immer die Frage, ob so ein Frank Schmidt dieses Heidenheim braucht, um zu funktionieren, oder ob das auch dann woanders geht.
Vielleicht ist er einfach so, er hat da gebaut, seine Kinder gehen in die Schule, hat er keinen Bock. Den Beamten-Job kündigst du ja auch nicht.
Soll ich euch übrigens sagen, wo wir Stefan Schmidt wiedersehen werden? Der ist jetzt der neue Trainer der Würzburger Kickers.
Ja, genau, daher habe ich es.
Was hat er jetzt die ganze Zeit gemacht? Also ich weiß, Paderborn, das war das Letzte, was ich noch im Sturm hatte.
Dann Energie Cottbus für 9 Spiele. Dann die Schalker U16. Dann aufgestiegen in die Schalker U17, wahrscheinlich sogar mit seinem Jahrgang, denke ich mal. Und jetzt eben die Kickers.
Also hat dann wieder ganz unten angefangen und sich wieder hochgearbeitet.
Hast du jetzt Schalke als ganz unten bezeichnet?
Nein, ganz unten nicht. Aber nachdem du ja Profi-Mannschaften trainiert hast, wird dir der Jugendbereich an, ist eher untypisch. Finde ich gut. Würde so ein Trainer wie Slomka zum Beispiel auch mal ganz gut zu Gesicht stehen?
Ja gut, der war auch beim KSC-Trainer ganz unten.
Nein, das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber guck dir mal die Karriere von Slomka an. Da sind immer sehr lange Pausen dabei. Das wird schon seine Gründe haben.
Wo soll der noch Trainer werden? Der findet bestimmt wieder einen Job. Der ist mit Karlsruhe als Letzte abgestiegen.
Der Letzte, der mit Karlsruhe in die 3. Liga aufgestiegen ist, ist mit Deutschland-Weltmeister geworden.
Ich stelle mir gerade Mirko Slomka als Nationaltrainer vor. Herzlichen Dank, Enzo. Das hast du geschafft. Wir gehen weiter in der Tabelle, landen bei Tabellenplatz 7. Schon hier treffen wir auf den FC St. Pauli. Das ist insofern besonders bemerkenswert, dass ihr euch vielleicht noch erinnern könnt. Im Winter haben wir als allerletztes über den FC St. Pauli gesprochen. Da lag man nämlich noch auf Tabellenplatz 18. Mit nur 11 Punkten. In der Rückrunden-Tabelle der 3. Tabellenplatz mit 34 Punkten. Also eine wahnsinnige Auffuhrjagd. Und das Ganze mit demselben Trainer. Man hat an Ewald Liden festgehalten, trotz aller Misere. Und es hat sich ausgezahlt. Ich freue mich für sowas bei jedem Verein. Das ist einfach schön. Könnt ihr mir diesen Wahnsinn-Rückrunden des FC St. Pauli zusammenfassen? Irgendwann hat sich das selbst bestätigt. Aber ich fand schon den Beginn in die Rückrunde. Das war ein richtiges Statement, oder, Sebastian?
Ja, also, was St. Pauli... Ich weiß gar nicht. Es gibt kaum Superlative, um das zu beschreiben, was St. Pauli da getrieben hat in der Rückrunde. Das ist einfach, wie du schon sagst, dass man wirklich cool bleibt und sagt, wir halten an dem Trainer fest, wir glauben an den Trainer. Und ziehen das jetzt gemeinsam durch, und dass das dann auch so gut bestätigt wird. Also, wirklich Wahnsinn. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir nicht erklären, was der mit der Mannschaft gemacht hat. Aber die haben auf einmal angefangen, Fußball zu spielen. Lautern hatte jetzt auch das Glück, in einem der letzten Saisonspiele zu Hause gegen St. Pauli zu spielen und zu verlieren. Die haben keinen Stich gesehen. St. Pauli hat das so eiskalt abgebrüht, abgezockt gemacht. Also wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz großen Respekt davor. Es zeigt aber auch, wie verrückt und wie krass die 2. Liga an sich ist, dass sie dann noch 7. werden können. Weil ich weiß auch damals, als wir gegen St. Pauli gespielt haben, hätten wir das Spiel gewonnen, wären wir 7. gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt. Gerade dieses Mittelfeld bis nach unten war sehr eng beieinander. Aber das soll nicht die Leistung von St. Pauli schmälern, das war einfach eine bombenstarke Rückrunde.
Ich fand ja, dass die in der Vorrunde auch ziemlich Pech hatten. Wen habe ich da gerade untergekauft?
Wie er schon sagte, in der Hinterrunde viel Pech. Die wurden in der Vorrunde für mich total unterbewertet. Die haben die Spiele immer nur ganz knapp verloren, haben auch mit Schiedsrichterentscheidungen zu kämpfen gehabt, waren nicht so schlecht im Spiel. Die haben teilweise schon gute Spiele abgeliefert, aber dann am Ende hinten raus unglücklich verloren. Da ist auch, glaube ich, Ewald Liemen irgendwann mal richtig ausgerastet. Und dann hat sich so eine gewisse, wie das halt so ist, so eine eigene Dynamik entwickelt und dann hat es selbst Frauen nicht mehr so gestimmt. Aber wie jetzt schon Sebastian gesagt hat, muss man hoch anrechnen, dass sie am Trainer festgehalten haben und dass die dann auch da den Turnaround geschafft haben.
Ich glaube auch, dass du sowas wie Spielplan als Faktor gar nicht unterschätzend hast. Wenn du gleich gegen Stuttgart und Hannover spielen musst, dann kriegst du gegen Stuttgart, da bist du sogar einst in Führung gegangen und verlierst in der letzten Minute 2-1. Dann musst du direkt gegen Hannover ran, den nächsten auf Absteiger. Ich glaube schon, dass da Mechanismen greifen, die es schwierig machen, die nächsten Spiele zu gewinnen. Einfach mit zwei Negativheit-Erlebnisse in die Saison startest.
Vor allem, wenn man sich vor Augen führt, wie die Ergebnisse in der Hinrunde zustande kamen. In der Rückrunde ging es eigentlich wieder ähnlich los, nämlich gegen euch im Heimspiel für St. Pauli wieder verloren 1-0. Aber dann startet eine Serie von 5 Spielen mit 4 Siegen und einem Unentschieden auf der Alm in Bielefeld. Man musste erst noch so wahnsinnig viele Punkte aufholen, um sich wieder ranzusaugen an die anderen Mannschaften. Dann Blinker gesetzt und zack, vorbei. Also wirklich krasse Saison. Ich finde es auch interessant, was jetzt im Nachhinein passiert ist, dass man nicht gesagt hat, ihr weit lieben Trainergott, du wirst für immer unser Jahrhundert-Trainer sein. Sondern dass man gesagt hat, okay, gut, was machen wir jetzt, wie reagieren wir auf das, wie Lin das sportliche Geschäft jetzt geführt hat und wie er es sieht und wie der ganze Verein sich zieht. Und man hebt Ewald Lin auf eine Ebene höher. Er wird technischer Direktor und Olaf Jansen, sein bisheriger Co-Trainer, wird jetzt Trainer. Ich finde das sehr interessant, weil sagt man ja immer so leicht, in den Zeichen des Erfolgs macht man die am häufigsten Fehler. Aber schaut euch mal an, was zum Beispiel Hannover 96 gemacht hat, als Fronzek ihn noch die Klasse bewahrt hat. Ein klassisches Beispiel für, wusste man damals schon, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gut gehen. Und finde ich echt interessant. St. Pauli hat da einen tollen Weg.
Ich glaube aber, es hat auch damit was zu tun, dass Ewald Lin selber nicht mehr so die Lust hat, da immer als Trainer im Mittelpunkt zu stehen. Ich habe ihn auch ein paar Mal erlebt, auf diversen Pressekonferenzen, Interviews, wie auch immer. Und ich glaube, dass es ihm einfach auch ein bisschen reicht. Das war jetzt echt eine anstrengende Zeit für ihn. Du hast ihn wirklich auch angemerkt, gerade als es nicht so lief. Er musste immer wieder dieselben Fragen beantworten, erklären, warum es nicht so läuft. Ich glaube, es hat ihm sehr, sehr, sehr viel Kraft gekostet. Klar, das Einfachste wäre zu denken, er hat jetzt eine Bomben-Rückrunde gespielt, warum macht er denn nicht weiter? Es kann doch eigentlich nur so weitergehen. Aber ich glaube wirklich, dass es ihn Körner gekostet hat. Evaldin ist jetzt nicht erst seitdem im Trainergeschäft, sondern macht es schon ein paar Jährchen. Wahrscheinlich hat er auch einfach Lust gehabt, jetzt mal zu sagen, Leute, nehmt mich mal jetzt hier raus. Ich gehe zwar an eine Ebene höher, bin aber eher weniger in der Öffentlichkeit als vorher und kann trotzdem meine Expertise an euch weitergeben und kann euch da helfen. Und ich glaube, dass das auch auf jeden Fall sehr viel Sinn macht.
Und es zeigt sich mal wieder, es hilft einfach, eine gute Defensive zu haben. Drittbeste Defensive der Liga. Weißt du zufällig, wer auf Platz 2 liegt, Sebastian?
Es könnte eine Mannschaft aus dem Südwesten Deutschland sein.
Jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen. Ja, ihr liegt im Südwesten, das ist korrekt. Keines ist Lautern tatsächlich. Nur Hannover und Kasus Lautern haben weniger Tore kassiert. Dann schon der FC St. Pauli.
Deswegen möchte ja auch ein Verein aus dem Norden Deutschlands unseren Torwart ganz gerne kaufen. Oder unter anderem deswegen. Weil der ziemlich oft zu Null gespielt hat.
Ach, guck an, das habe ich zum Beispiel noch gar nicht mitbekommen. Welchen Verein aus dem Norden meinst du?
Naja, den Hamburger SV.
Die brauchen auch einen neuen.
Den Verein aus dem Norden, über den wir eigentlich in diesem Podcast sprechen müssen. Weil es eigentlich verdient hätte, mal in die 2. Liga abzusteigen. Aber irgendwie ist es dann doch der Dino. Und irgendwie geht es für mich dann trotzdem in Ordnung, dass sie nicht abgestiegen sind. Aber eigentlich, wenn es eine Mannschaft verdient hätte, mal abzusteigen, wäre es der HSV.
Lasst uns in dieses Thema besser nicht reingehen. Mit Blick auf die Uhr. Wenn wir kurz noch zu St. Pauli, kurz noch auch auf die Mannschaft selber gucken. St. Buhadouche, Super-Saison gemacht, 15 Tore erzielt. War unheimlich wichtig, auch so ein bisschen mit Ansage. Man wusste, St. Pauli braucht jemand, der vorne Treffer markieren kann. Denn so viele waren es jetzt auch gar nicht. Insgesamt dann 39 Tore. Da sieht man auch, was die 15 von Buhadouche wert waren. Ansonsten lasst das Objekt, glaube ich, eine Super-Saison gemacht. Shahin auch, Buchtmann, Sobotta. Also, ist eigentlich sogar schwierig, da jetzt einzelne rauszuheben. Aber da kann man ja den Übersteiger-Podcast hören.
Ja, aber jetzt eine gute Saison. Die haben nur okay in dieser Saison gespielt. Die sind zur 7. geworden am Ende. Aber die waren halt bis Spieltag 28 auf dem Abschiebsplatz. Das darf man halt nicht vergessen. So gut war es dann am Ende dann nicht. Wenn du eine Analyse machst, ernsthaft, dann muss man schon sagen, eigentlich war es eine kacke Saison, wo du dich am Ende noch gut gerettet hast.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Weil die Frage ist, was ist die Ausgangsbasis? Ich hätte St. Pauli schon vorher eher im Mittelfeld der Liga gesehen, wo man jetzt ja am oberen Rand des Mittelfelds auch irgendwie rausgekommen ist. Aber wenn ich mir den Kader angucke, dann hat man doch eigentlich jetzt mit diesem 7. Platz am Ende das aus dem Kader so nahe des Optimums rausgeholt. Und natürlich ist der Verlauf sehr kurios. Du hast diese Talsohle-Hinrunde und du hast die Berganstieg-Rückrunde. Aber unter dem Strich ist es doch dann doch eine erfolgreiche Saison. Ich finde, es ist keine Kack-Saison.
Wenn du nur den 34. Spieltag nimmst, dann die Tabelle nimmst und sagst, ok, wir sind 7. geworden. Was wollte er denn? Ist doch so toll. Aber du kannst dir halt nicht erlauben, nochmal so eine Saison zu spielen. Du weißt nicht, wie oft das gut geht.
Das ist natürlich wahr, ja, das stimmt.
Also ich würde da schon drauf achten, dass das nächste Jahr vielleicht nicht ganz so läuft. Weil, wie gesagt, zwei Drittel ist auch was auf dem Abschiebsplatz.
Ja, okay, das stimmt natürlich, ja. Aber ich glaube, wir reden da eigentlich sogar über zwei verschiedene Sachen. Wollt ihr anderen noch irgendwas ergänzen zu St. Pauli, oder sollen wir weitermachen?
Ich möchte nur noch ergänzen, dass der von dir schon erwähnte Übersteiger-Podcast auf jeden Fall hörungswert ist. Und auch nochmal Grüße an die Kollegen übrigens.
Absolut, absolut. Es gibt tolle zweitige Casts. Die sollte ich am Ende auch nochmal aufzählen. Sebastian erinnert mich da bitte dran. Absolut. Wir gehen weiter. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Lieblingsverein, über den der Stefan uns ganz viel erzählt. Möchten wir reden über Greuther Fürth? Was musste denn bei Greuther Fürth klappen, Stefan, damit man vor dem Klub landen konnte mit diesem Stadion?
Das sind ja nur drei Punkte. Es war natürlich der glückliche Hinterundensee, den sie gegen uns hatten. Da waren wir eigentlich ganz klar die bessere Mannschaft. Die haben dadurch einen abgefälschten Treckschuss, wie es unser ehemaliger Trainer immer gerne formulierte, das Spiel noch geworden.
Ja, aber da zieht dir gerne einen großartigen Gast in dieser Sendung. Wenn du eine ordentliche Analyse machen willst, dann kannst du das nicht auf ein Spiel runterbrechen. Also ernsthaft gesprochen, du bist ja näher dran, glaube ich, als wir alle an den Greuther Fürth gingen.
Verdammt nah dran, aber doch weit weg.
Genau, emotionale Distanz bei lokaler Nähe. Das kann es durchaus geben. Ich habe ja auch schon Sendungen zu 1860 gemacht. Was war das für eine Saison? Nur 33 erzielte Tore ist nicht arg besonders. Ein achter Tabellenplatz, aber irgendwie schon auch okay für das, was da in Fürth Jahr für Jahr passiert, oder?
Ja, insgesamt würde ich sagen, also wie gesagt, ich bin da wirklich emotional, auch medial schenke ich den Fürthern jetzt nicht so viel Beachtung. Es liegt, glaube ich, einfach in der Natur der Sache. Aber sie machen es jetzt halt auch, man muss es so sagen, über Jahre hinweg eigentlich ordentlich. Also auch in diesem Jahr, ich glaube, mit dem Abstieg hatten sie wirklich nie was zu tun, mit dem Aufstieg zwar auch nicht, immer so im Mittelfeld und ich glaube, das ist auch für das Spielermaterial, was sie haben, insgesamt in Ordnung.
Das finde ich war angenehm zurückhalten. Sebastian, wie siehst du denn für die sind für mich geführt? Es gibt so eine Klasse von Zweitliga-Vereinen, bei denen ich jetzt nicht nachgeguckt habe, wie lange sie jetzt schon Zweitliga-Angehörige sind, aber die für mich, das ist einfach so eine klassische Zweitliga-Mannschaft inzwischen geworden. Zu denen gehört leider, muss man sagen, auch der FCK, aber auch Fürth. Sorry, so gefühlt einfach.
Das, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist eigentlich genau das, was ich auch als erstes sagen wollte. Fürth ist für mich so ein bisschen, wenn ich in der Zweite Liga im Lexikon nachschaue, dann finde ich da Greuther Fürth irgendwie. Also gefühlt schon immer dabei, auch ganz, ganz oft wirklich oben mit dabei. Und ich glaube, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was der persönliche Anspruch in Fürth war dieses Jahr, aber wenn man sich mal anschaut, welche Mannschaften da davor stehen, dann ist das, glaube ich, unterm Strich doch eine erfolgreiche Saison, weil du hast eigentlich nur Mannschaften, gut, wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen, Dresden ein bisschen überraschend, Heidenheim, naja, machen eben solide Arbeit. Aber du hast eigentlich fast nur Mannschaften vorne dran, wo klar war oder wo man sich hätte eigentlich denken können, ok, ja, da kommen wir diese Saison nicht dran vorbei. Von daher ist aus meiner Sicht Fürth ein achter Saisonplatz gut.
Interessante Statistik gehört auf Platz 1 der ewigen Tabelle in der Zweiten Liga und erreicht durchschnittlich Tabelle in Platz 7,9 laut bundesliga.de. Ja, dann passt Platz 8 natürlich auch extrem gut.
Und das ist auch überhaupt nicht überraschend. Wie konnten wir eigentlich von irgendetwas anderem ausgehen? Ok, so viel zu Kräuter Fürth oder so wenig, aber da könnt ihr den lieben Tiffer auf Twitter fragen. Der kann uns noch viel, viel mehr erzählen. Den hole ich in den nächsten Rasenfunk Royal XS. Habe ich den nächsten Royal XS gerade angekündigt? Ich glaube schon. Folgt ihr der grandiosen Seite Pot-Originale? Das ist eine Facebook-Seite zu einem Film. Kennt ihr die? Ich möchte euch herausfordern und auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, das zu tun, folgt Pot-Originale bei Facebook. Denn ihr werdet noch mal einen komplett anderen Blick auf den VfL Bochum bekommen. Das ist ein fantastischer Film. Und auf der Facebook-Seite werden ganz viele Protagonisten, die in dem Film vorkommen, weiter begleitet. Und das sind eben VfL Bochum-Fans. Da gibt es dann zum Beispiel den Tankwart. Guckt es euch einfach an, hat meinen Blick auch auf die Bochum-Saison, ehrlich gesagt, mitgeprägt, dass ich dann irgendwann vor allem über diese Informationsquelle was mitbekommen habe. Letztes ist die Frage. Stefan, was darüber hinaus? Na gut, du kannst ja nicht wissen, was der Tankwart so gemacht hat. Aber was kennzeichnet denn die Saison vom VfL Bochum? Und ist es gerechtfertigt, wenn wir auch an der Stelle vor allem über den Trainer sprechen, oder tut man da mit der Mannschaft ein bisschen unrecht?
Ich glaube, man muss über den Trainer sprechen. Ich kenne ja Gert-Jan Verbeek auch ein bisschen aus der 2. Nürnberg.
Du machst jeden Elfmeter. Ich kann es nur nochmal wiederholen.
Gerne. Und man guckt natürlich immer, was ehemalige Trainer oder ehemalige Spieler im eigenen Verein so machen. Und Verbeek macht das, was er auch in Nürnberg gemacht hat. Also in Nürnberg ging es schief. In der 2. Liga läuft es ein bisschen besser. Man sieht es auch mit den 47 Gegentoren, die sie haben. Offensiv ist es natürlich immer Hui, was da abgeht. Aber defensiv ist es dann halt oftmals auch Pui. Ich kann mich da auch an Spiele erinnern, die ich so auch erlebt habe in Nürnberg mit Gert-Jan Verbeek. Zum Beispiel einmal in der 1. Liga gegen Hannover 96, wo man in Hannover 3-0 führt. Und dann geht es hinten raus 3-3 auch aus, weil man eben vergisst, den Ladendicht zu machen. Solche Spiele habe ich in Bochum auch gesehen. In dieser Saison kann ich mich jetzt nicht so erinnern. Vielleicht auch das Spiel gegen uns. 5-4 haben wir ja in Bochum verloren. Ein Ergebnis, das auch nicht oft zustande zusammenkommt. Aber das spiegelt auch so, das zeigt auch so, wie Gerd Verbeek so tickt. In der letzten Saison, ich glaube, da haben sie auch mal 3-0 gegen FSV Frankfurt zu Hause geführt und dann auch 3-3 gespielt. Und ich sehe noch immer Gerd-Jan Verbeek am Spielfeldrand, beim Spielstand von 3-0, wo der FSV alles nach vorne wirft, wo er seine Mannschaft nach vorne schickt, wo ich mir denke, nee, mach doch mal lieber den Laden hinten dicht. Das ist für mich so der Fall für Bochum. Ich glaube, in diesem Jahr mussten sie natürlich auch an dem Abgang von Terotte knabbern, denn den haben sie auch nicht ersetzt bekommen, ist natürlich klar. Aber wenn man über den VfL Bochum spricht, muss man natürlich auch über Gerd-Jan Verbeek sprechen.
Ich ärgere mich diese Saison eher extrem, weil ich dachte, geil, wieder Bochum, schön Freitagabend am besten noch. Dann macht die DFL, tut die DFL mit den Gefallen, dass das Spiel außer Spiel in Bochum Freitagabend ist. Dann freitags sitze ich halt bis um halb acht im Büro, konnte nicht zum Spiel.
Und darüber hinaus...
Woll ich nur kurz erwähnt haben, ganz kurz.
Du hast unser ungeteiltes Mitleid, wobei es sich bei den beiden Gästen hier, die in der 2. Liga verbleiben dürfen, wahrscheinlich in Grenzen noch irgendwo hält.
Wie macht ihr das mit den Anschlusszeiten? Das war eine Vollkatastrophe, ging gar nicht für mich.
Man gewöhnt sich an alles. Am Wochenende geht es, also auch Freitagabend, 18.30 Uhr oder Montag, 20.15 Uhr, es geht. Am schlimmsten fand ich die englischen Wochen, wo die 2. Liga dann um 19.30 Uhr ein. Das wird für mich auch ein Problem, da dann pünktlich aus zur Arbeit zu kommen.
Rein von der Uhrzeit her, zumindest für die Heimspiele, ist fast schon der Montag am besten, weil das Viertel nach Acht ist.
Für mich als Fan der nicht in der gleichen Stadt, wo natürlich traumhaft. Sport 1 gucken, Montagabends, das passt. Aber das Rest geht gar nicht.
Aber für Auswärtsfahrer ist das natürlich eine Katastrophe.
Ich muss auch mal als jemand sagen, der mit seinem Verein noch nie abgestiegen ist, das können wir jetzt gerne Leute auch als Arroganz auslegen, aber bei mir tickt die Bundesliga-Uhr so krass auf 15.30 Uhr. Also an jedem Samstag um 15.30 Uhr oder eigentlich ehrlich gesagt so 14.30 Uhr wird man so langsam so ein bisschen hibbelig. Ab 15 Uhr stellt man sich ständig die Frage, wo kann ich die Spiele verfolgen? Und um 15.30 Uhr geht es dann los. Und ich war auch schon bei Zweitliga-Spielen. Und jedes Mal ging es mir so, ich war an einem Sonntagsspiel gegen Lautern, übrigens Sebastian, in Ingolstadt. Da waren insgesamt 10.000 Zuschauer, glaube ich. Es war ein November. Nein, es waren nicht mal 10.000, es waren 8.000. 2.000 davon waren Lauterer. Wir standen im Block direkt neben Lautern zusammen mit 13 anderen Leuten. Die habe ich alle gezählt. Und das war halt so ein Sonntag-Mittagsspiel. Und das hat für mich sich überhaupt nicht nach Fußball angefühlt. Weil für mich ist Fußball um diese Tageszeit entweder direkt am Sportplatz meines Heimatvereins und mit sehr, sehr wenig Fußball, dafür eine ganz guten Wurscht und netten Leuten. Oder ich gucke gerade irgendwas im Fernsehen, irgendeine Zusammenfassung. Ansonsten findet Fußball zu dieser Uhrzeit für mich nicht statt. Und meine Bundesliga-Uhr war da überhaupt nicht darauf eingestellt.
Ich bin nach Köln gezogen, bin spieler der FC, überraschenderweise in der 2. Liga. Und da gab es die Dauerkarten für 80 Euro für Studenten. Und da gab es noch immer Dauerkarten. Das ist nicht so lange her. Das ist 13 Jahre her, als ich angefangen habe zu studieren in Köln. Und da kommst du gefühlt gerade aus dem Club und musst am Sonntag schon wieder Bier trinken im Stadion. Das war schon sehr strange. Das war so ein kreißiger A. Die Reserve-Mannschaften, die kreißige A-Mannschaften, fingen ja auch immer um Surfer 15 an zu spielen.
Wobei ganz ehrlich in meiner Studentenzeit in Freiburg fand ich das noch sehr, sehr geil, weil da waren für mich die Sonntagsspiele immer halt so der Auftakt. Danach sitzen wir noch an der Dreisam und dann sitzen wir bei mir auf der Terrasse.
Direkt nach dem Frühstück zum Spielen.
Ja gut, ich hab vorher tatsächlich nicht direkt Frühstück, aber genau, naja, anderes Thema jetzt. Aber weil jetzt Stefan schon so viel die Offensive betont hat beim VfL, was ja auch stimmt, Gert-Jan Fabik lässt einen offensiven Fußball spielen. Es ist aber nicht wirklich viel dabei rausgekommen in dieser Saison. Nur 42 Tore erzielt, 47 gefangen. Und die Top-Torschützen sind Wurz und Mlapper mit jeweils 8 Treffern. Müssen wir das dann auf fehlende Spieler wie Terodde beschränken? Also Enzo, habt ihr da die Konkurrenz einfach schwach gekauft und deswegen ging es nicht besser beim VfL?
Also wir haben ja jetzt nicht irgendeinen Spieler von denen gekauft, sondern wirklich mit den besten Zweiten Liga-Spielern, die es auf dem Markt gab. Von daher ist das, das kannst du nicht kompensieren. Das kriegst du nicht hin. Also gerade wenn du einen Trainer hast, der dir viel nach vorne spielen lässt und lieber 5-4 gewinnt als 1-0 oder so, dann kriegst du das nicht gebacken. Also dann hast du keine Chance mehr. Dann kommt halt so eine Saison raus. Und das ist glaube ich aber für Bochum auch jetzt nicht so, ich verfolge Bochum ja nicht jetzt seit Jahren intensiv, sondern ich glaube, das ist okay für die, oder? Platz 9 können die mit leben. Oder habe ich denn eine Frage nicht richtig verstanden und ich habe ganz was anderes gesagt jetzt?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Du hast im Grunde gesagt, ne doch, wir können es auf den Spieler, der da weggegangen ist, eingrenzen.
Ja, das ist doch so. Man schrifft ja immer, dass die Bayern, Dortmund die Spieler verkaufen. Aber so ein Hummelswerk zu kaufen, dann schadest du vielleicht der Abwehr, aber nicht dem ganzen System von Dortmund. Wenn du aber natürlich einen Terratte, der wahrscheinlich das ganze System auf ihn ausgelegt ist, wegkaufst, dann geht das nicht mehr. Dann hast du keine Chance.
Aber sind wir doch mal ehrlich und schauen uns auch in dem Fall, wie es schon bei FÜRD anfällt, welche Mannschaften vor Bochum stehen. Und dann muss man, glaube ich, unterm Strich auch in Bochum sagen, es war jetzt keine überragende Saison, aber wir haben ein paar Große hinter uns gelassen, bei denen es nicht so lief. Und ansonsten weiß ich nicht, wie viel weiter vorne Bochum hätte stehen sollen.
Ja, das hat Enzo im Grunde auch gerade gesagt. Ich glaube auch, das war eine erfolgreiche Saison und zwischendurch sah es ja auch mal schlechter aus. Und dann ist so ein neunter Platz am Ende dann auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Und mit den Großen, die Bochum hinter sich gelassen hat, hast du, Sebastian, ja sicher auch den SV Sandhausen gemeint.
Definitiv ein großer Zweitliga-Verein. Ja, man muss schon sagen, ich habe Sandhausen ja auch relativ am Anfang schon mal erwähnt. Und Sandhausen ist für mich ähnlich wie Fürth mittlerweile eine typische Zweitligamannschaft, die es aber wie gesagt schafft, mit relativ solider Arbeit eine ordentliche Saison zu spielen. Man muss dazu sagen, Sandhausen war und ist für mich und für viele andere auch lange Zeit so eine Art kleine Zweigstelle des FCK gewesen, weil einfach unglaublich viele Spieler und ja lange Zeit auch der Trainer Alois Schwartz eine FCK-Vergangenheit hatten. Man hat da wirklich Linzmeier, Wuthen, Knaller, der Keeper, sind alles Spieler, die früher mal in Lautern waren und da nicht so wirklich den großen Durchbruch geschafft haben. Und irgendwie hat der Alois Schwartz damals schon geschafft, das alles so ein bisschen zusammenzuhalten. Gut, dann ist er natürlich irgendwann weg. Aber die Arbeit wird da trotzdem relativ solide fortgeführt. Und von daher, also Sandhausen macht das ordentlich. Und viel mehr nach oben, nach unten, weiß ich nicht. Was ich sagen muss, ich war jetzt schon zweimal dort. Es ist wirklich Provinz. Und dieses Stadion ist auch nicht wirklich, gerade wenn der Gästeblock gefüllt ist, zweitligatauglich. Schöne Anekdote dazu. Wir waren mal in Sandhausen bei einem Auswärtsspiel und wollten in den Gästeblock rein. Und dann hieß es vom Ordner, der Block ist voll. Und darauf haben wir dann gesagt, wie kann das sein? Wir haben ja hier unsere Karten für diesen Block. Ja, nee, der Block ist voll. Kurze Wartezeit. Dann kam ein anderer Ordner, hat uns außenrum über ein Feld und ein anderes kleines Fußballfeld geführt und hat dann von hinten ein Tor aufgeschlossen. Und die Leute, die von vorne nicht reinkamen, kamen von hinten quasi in den Block nachgeschoben. Und so sind wir dann ins Stadion gekommen. Das ist so eine Anekdote aus Sandhausen.
Ja, eine Anekdote, die die DFL nicht so gerne hören wird.
Tja, dann soll sich die DFL bitte an Sandhausen richten. Wobei, ich glaube, die Spiele, bei denen der Zuschauerandrang so groß in Sandhausen ist, lassen sich auch an relativ bescheidenen Fingern abzählen. Also ich glaube, die Probleme haben sie nicht oft.
Das könnte tatsächlich wahr sein. Auf jeden Fall auch eine sehr gute Defensivmannschaft. Sandhausen, viertbeste Defensive. Wenn wir vorhin mit St. Pauli die drittbeste Mannschaft hatten, dann ist Sandhausen hier direkt dahinter einzuordnen. Und nach dem, was ich so gehört habe und dann zum Teil auch gesehen habe, es ist einfach unangenehm, gegen Sandhausen zu spielen. Die Gegner müssen sehr körperbetont spielen. Und es ist einfach kein leichter Gegner. Und das, glaube ich, fasst Sandhausen ganz gut zusammen. Der aktuelle Zuschausschnitt, übrigens bei 6.700 Zuschauern in dieser Saison, das war neuer Rekord für den SV Sandhausen. Vielleicht hat er auch...
Das wäre auch interessant, wenn wir 5.000 Einwohner haben.
Und sie hatten kein einziges ausverkauftes Spiel in dieser Saison. Wahrscheinlich schon satt alle. Auch nicht gegen Hannover und so?
Liegen die nicht auch in diesen Dreieck? Kaiserslautern, Karlsruhe. Vielleicht auch noch Stuttgarter Einzugsgebiet. Ich glaube, da wird es schwer, als so kleiner Club dann da eine Fanbasis aufzubauen.
Also Einwohner sind Stand 31. Dezember 2015, 14.902. Das heißt, damit müsste man das Stadion doch, glaube ich, vollkriegen. Ja, wahrscheinlich war es auch gegen Hannover deshalb nicht ausverkauft, weil man da aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht alles...
In Fürth haben sie mehr Einwohner und die kriegen das Stadion auch nicht voll.
Ja gut, vielleicht sind da ja auch viele mit einer lokalen Nähe und einer emotionalen Distanz da. Übrigens, generell hatte Sandhausen, zumindest jetzt laut transfermarkt.de, in seiner kompletten Historie erst ein ausverkauftes Spiel. Und das war in der Aufstiegssaison in die 2. Liga, also als man aufgestiegen war, wahrscheinlich der Auftakt. Nun ja, wollen wir jetzt mal nicht irgendwie hier grundlos über Sandhausen lästern. Sportlich ist es ja durchaus aller Ehren wert. Was man jetzt schon zum wiederholten Male geschafft hat, haben wir ja, finde ich, ganz gut eingeordnet. Und dann haben wir im wunderschönen, wie ich finde, Intro einen Fortuna-Fan gehört, die überall mit dabei war, auf Acker, im Stadion. Und jetzt soll die Fortuna endlich mal aufsteigen. Das sollte der Dame wieder nicht vergönnt sein, Stefan, denn die Fortuna liegt auf Tabellenplatz 11. Und der Fokus ging auch lange Zeit eher nach unten. Was ist denn da in dieser Saison? Ist etwas schiefgelaufen oder müssen wir uns jetzt darauf einstellen, dass jetzt jede Fortuna-Saison so läuft? Was ist da zusammengekommen, Stefan?
Ja, 42 Punkte. Also wenn man sich die Tabelle anschaut zwischen Platz 6 und Platz 13, da liegen, glaube ich, 5 Punkte. Das ist jetzt nicht so viel. Aber natürlich gefühlt, wenn man die Fortuna in dieser Saison anschaut, waren die natürlich immer mehr unten angesiedelt als oben. Aber so unterm Strich, wenn man sich den Kader anguckt, da ist jetzt auch kein Superspieler dabei, wo du sagst, den hätte ich jetzt aber gerne auch in meinem Kader. Ich glaube, das ist alles in Ordnung. Wenn man da 42 Punkte holt, nicht absteigt bei den ganzen Umständen. Ich glaube, die Fortuna ist jetzt auch nicht finanziell gesegnet. Ich glaube, es ist auch alles ordentlich, was da gelaufen ist. Wir haben natürlich mit Friedhelm Funkel einen Trainer gehabt, der zweite Erfahrung hatte, der wusste, wie das funktioniert. Ja, also so genau habe ich die Fortuna nicht beobachtet, aber so aus der Ferne würde ich sagen, ist das schon in Ordnung, was da passiert ist.
Genau, wenn man sich den Verlauf anguckt, dann nie wirklich in Gefahr nach unten hin. Alles ganz safe, entspannt ist es so. Auch, wenn sie wollten aufsteigen, das war ein bisschen scheiße, aber das will in Düsseldorf, glaube ich, nicht wirklich jemand.
Ich habe mir gerade angeguckt, wie die Fortuna so hat spielen lassen und bin beim 34. Spieltag rausgekommen. Da stand man schön entspanntes 5-4-1 im Heimspiel gegen Erzgebirge Aue auf dem Rasen. Friedhelm Funkel lässt grüßen, aber ich tue ihm eben so für ein Unrecht, dass er eigentlich einen 4-1-4-1 hat spielen lassen. Diese Fünferkette war eine Ausnahme, aber irgendwie ja auch krass, weil da konnte doch nichts mehr passieren in diesem Spiel. 39 Punkte hatte man da. Nein, und dann gibt man dagegen Erzgebirge Aue, für die es noch um etwas ging, als Aufsteiger in einem 5-4-1 ins letzte Heimspiel der Saison. Das ist Trockenbrot, finde ich.
Aber immerhin haben es fast 38.000 Zuschauer noch mal gesehen.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich meine, das ist schon ein interessanter Aspekt, der die Zuschauer zahlen in der 2. Liga. Also Fortuna mit einem Schnitt von 26.000 in der Saison. Wir reden gerade über Sandhausen mit 6.000. Natürlich vergleichen wir auch unterschiedliche Regionen miteinander. Und es darf auch ruhig schon beides geben. Es muss ja nicht nur Vereine geben, die immer 40.000 im Stadion haben. Aber es ist halt schon ein Aspekt, der irgendwie mit reinkommt. Das finde ich schon interessant. Und 37 Tore erzielt, 39 gefangen. Es ist wirklich eine Klischee-Funkel-Saison. Mir ist auch kein einziges Ausreißerspiel im Gedächtnis. Oder vergesse ich da jetzt gerade irgendein 6 zu 0 oder 4 zu 4? Ein 4-0 gab es mal gegen Bielefeld zu Hause.
Ich finde auch, es ist der perfekte Verein Florenzen. Er wollte eigentlich immer ein bisschen mehr, aber gibt sich damit auch zufrieden, dass er Mittelmaß ist.
Was sagt denn Max dazu als alter Rensinkennner von früher?
Na, wie sage ich das jetzt, ohne es zu sagen? Ich glaube, dass Düsseldorf nicht denselben Plusfaktor hat wie Heidenheim, bei dem wir gesagt haben, man hört ganz selten, dass Spieler da auch mal zu viel feiern. Und dahingehend könnte das dann vielleicht auch ganz gut passen. Also vielleicht ist es dann ein Perfect Match.
Willst du etwa sagen, dass es die längste Theke der Welt dazu einlädt? Oder ausschweifende Erlebnisse im Nachtleben?
Nein, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Rensink oder irgendwelche anderen Spieler ein ausschweifendes Nachtleben haben, aber da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung von. Aber als ich Rensink noch bei München erleben konnte, hat man gesehen, ich will jetzt überhaupt nicht sagen, dass der besoffen zum Training oder sonst wie gekommen ist. Aber das gehört, glaube ich, für ihn zu seinem Leben als Profifußballer schon mit dazu, dass man in schicken Cafés sitzen kann und da sein Latte Macchiato schlürft und dass man noch mal vielleicht so einen Aperol-Spritz irgendwo nimmt. So das, was du hier in München easy machen kannst. Und ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen, Düsseldorf ist da nicht die schlechteste Stadt für.
Das ist aber ein interessanter Aspekt. Also hat da vielleicht sein Verein tatsächlich auch nach diesem Kriterium auch zugeschaut.
Wo war der denn? War der jetzt in Leverkusen oder war der in Köln? Wo war der denn davor nochmal? Der wollte auf jeden Fall nicht weg von hier, aus der Region. Scheiße, wo war denn der jetzt noch? Spieler, der Rensing, mein Gott.
Rensing war bei Köln und dann bei Leverkusen.
Genau, genau. Und der wollte wirklich aus dem Rheinland nicht weg. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Düsseldorf dann wirklich so... Es ging nicht anders. Alternativlos für ihn war.
Aber ich will es jetzt wirklich nicht darauf reduzieren, dass der irgendwie fein geht. Ehrlich, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Aber Lebensgefühl und so weiter, so meinte ich das. Wir sind ja nicht bei 3.90, ich möchte nicht verklagt werden. Ich habe keine Advokat. War das ein Witz, Enzo, oder habt ihr wirklich eine Advokat?
Ich frage mich nach, ich war ja ein paar Wochen außer Gefecht, aber ich hoffe, dass wir eine haben, weil ich verlasse mich drauf.
Wobei, die anderen hauen da noch mal deutlicher drauf. Naja, die Fortuna kommt raus auf Tabellenplatz 11. Ich denke, wir sind ihrer kompletten Saison jetzt nicht gerecht geworden mit diesem kurzen Segment, aber es ist auch ehrlich gesagt schwierig. Und bevor ich jetzt hier irgendwelche Dinge mir aus der Nase ziehe, 37 Tore geschossen, 39 gefangen, das kann ich sagen, 42 Punkte, das kann ich sagen, unter Tabellenplatz 11.
Lass mich... eine kleine Sache, bevor wir weitergehen, noch zu Fortuna Düsseldorf. Fortuna Düsseldorf hat natürlich auch Axel Bellinghausen im Kader.
Warum wusste ich, dass du jetzt wieder mit irgendeinem Lauterer ums Eck kommst?
Den berühmten Wadenbeißer. Aber ich möchte über Axel Bellinghausen, der ein super geiler Typ ist, einfach nur sagen, dass er mannschaftsintern beim FCK mal den Spitznamen Axel Balim aushatte. Und damit möchte ich gerne das Kapitel Fortuna Düsseldorf beenden.
Sehr schön, das ist quasi eure Version des Entlaubers. Gut, kommen wir zu Stefan. Stefan ist Fan des 1. FC Nürnberg und spricht darüber, schreibt darüber, twittert darüber unter dem Handel Clubfans United und Stefan, du darfst uns jetzt sagen, was das für eine Saison war, die euch auf den Tabellenplatz 12 geführt hat und bitte.
Eine viel zu lange Nachbetrachtung, als sie wollte nicht aufhören. Sie wollte einfach nicht aufhören. Unsere Saison hat ja eh schon sehr früh begonnen.
Am ersten Spieltag?
Ne, schon viel früher. Erstmal haben wir noch an der Relegation lange geknappert, dass das nicht geklappt hat. Dann hat uns überraschend, wo wir alle dachten, dass dieses Trainerkarussell an uns vorübergeht, hat uns Rene Weiler in Richtung Belgien zu Anderlecht verlassen. Damit ging unsere Saison eigentlich schon los. So scheiße, wir haben keinen Trainer. Wer wird Trainer? Die berühmte T-Frage in Nürnberg, die wir immer wieder mal führen.
Dabei stellt man die T-Frage doch eher in Fürth.
Ein Brüller am Rande. Ja, es ging schon ziemlich früh los für uns. Auch emotional viele Diskussionen geführt. Wer wird Trainer? Das war nicht lange klar. Dann ist es aloes schwarz geworden, weil das Portfolio da einfach sportlich komplett passte. Hatte an Sandhausen mit wenigen Mitteln viel erreicht, immer wieder die Klasse erhalten, doch trotz Punkt-Azug immer einen Mittelfeldplatz erreicht. Ich glaube, als Verein wollte man da kein großes Risiko eingehen. Deswegen hat man wahrscheinlich auch die 400.000 Euro in die Hand genommen. Auch medial war das in Nürnberg mit aloes schwarz eine logische Entscheidung. Dann lief es am Anfang irgendwie gar nicht, weil es war nicht klar, wer kommt noch, wer geht noch. Wir hatten noch keine Mannschaft zusammen am 1. Spieltag. Ich glaube, erst gegen Ende August, wo wir schon 3 Spieltage gespielt haben, kam Matthausch zu uns ins Team, der dann Füllkrug ersetzt hat. Wir werden sicher noch ein bisschen genauer darüber sprechen, aber insgesamt war es eine sehr, sehr lange Saison für uns. Wir waren jetzt am Ende froh, dass es endlich vorbei war.
Du hast diesen schlimmen Start schon angesprochen. Am 6. Spieltag, dann Tabellenplatz 18, gekrönt noch von einer Heimiederlage im Derby gegen Fürth. Haben wir vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen. Aber es sollte ja zwischenzeitlich besser werden, Stefan. Es war ja nicht alles schlecht. Dann eine Siegeserie gestartet. Ich glaube, die nächsten zwei, vier, sechs, acht Spiele ungeschlagen, sechs Siege, zwei unentschieden. Hat da irgendetwas gegriffen, was vorher nicht funktioniert hat? War das so ein bisschen, na ja, manchmal kommt man ja irgendwie so auch selber ins Rollen oder hat Schwarz da was umgestellt? Was war da los?
Ja, also unser Schlussspieler, wie es halt bei vielen Mannschaften auch ist, Gülio Burgstaller, ist langsam in Form gekommen. Habst du, glaube ich, im Anfang schon mal gesagt, er wollte eigentlich weg, aber wir konnten ihn eigentlich nicht verkaufen, weil wir so einen Adalas hat Bornemann dann Gott sei Dank nicht zugelassen. Und ich glaube, das hat mir Burgstaller auch angemerkt, ein bisschen lustlos, war ein bisschen schwierig. Ich habe damals schon gesagt, Mensch, hätten wir doch diesen Burgstaller doch verkauft und hätten wir uns jemanden anders geholt. Also soweit war ich schon damals. Und dann plötzlich aber mit dem Bielefeldspiel, wo wir da 3-1 gewonnen haben, dann plötzlich lief es. Dann hat Burgstaller dieses Tiefe bewunden, hat sich mit der Situation abgefunden und hat ja wieder Spaß im Fußball gespielt. Dann hat er auch wieder die wichtigen Tore für uns gemacht und dann lief es auch plötzlich. Wir haben nie jetzt überragend gespielt, aber wir haben effektiv gespielt. Es war eigentlich in Ordnung, was wir gemacht haben. Ich glaube, dass wir da bis Ende der Hinrunde vom Spieltag 7 bis 17 Tabellenführer waren, das hat auch das widergespiegelt, was auf dem Platz lief. Wir haben auch die großen Mannschaften geschlagen. Wir haben zu Hause Union Berlin geschlagen. Wir haben Hannover zu Hause geschlagen. Das war alles in Ordnung.
Ich meine, ihr habt sechs Spiele nicht gewonnen.
Ja, die gab es. Die gab es am ersten Spieltag. Das war natürlich ab dem ersten Spieltag dieses 1-1, wo wir in der fünften Minute der Nachspielzeit in Dresden den Ausgleich bekommen. Da war die Trainer-Diskussion schon sehr früh da, was mich sehr überrascht hat. Aber das lag natürlich auch ein bisschen an Alois Schwarz selbst, der glaube ich, sportlich kann man ihm bestimmt einiges vorwerfen, aber nicht so viel, dass es zu so massiver Kritik reicht. Aber seine Außendarstellung war natürlich katastrophal. Also er kam natürlich von diesem beschaulichen Sandhausen, da gab es einen Journalisten, der ist nicht mal mit aufs Auswärtsspiel gefahren, der hat Schwarz dann nach dem Spiel angerufen und gefragt, wie es war so ungefähr. Der kam hier nach Nürnberg, das war ja schon beim Trainingsauftakt so, da hat mein Kollege von Club Fence United über ihn ein bisschen dispektierlich gesagt, Alois im Wunderland, weil er so überrascht war, wie toll doch und wie groß doch dieses Trainingsgelände ist und wie toll doch hier die Bedingungen sind und dass das doch alles so ganz anders ist als in Sandhausen. Ja, damit hat er sich jetzt keine Freunde gemacht und er hat es am Ende nicht geschafft, die Fans auf seine Seite zu holen. Er war da einfach medial, einfach zu blass. Das war so sein großes Hauptproblem, glaube ich.
Würdest du damit sagen, dass es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen Nürnberg und Sandhausen von den Trainingsbedingungen?
Ich glaube ja.
Kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Ich finde es eher interessant, dass man sich mit dem Lob der Trainingsbedingungen unbeliebt machen kann bei den eigenen Fans. Du sollst es hier hassen, verdammt.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so eine Nürnberger Mentalität. Da kommt ein neuer Trainer und das erste, was er sagt, ist es schön zu trainieren, ist das toll. Da kam auch dieser Spruch, Alois im Wunderland. Da haben wir schon ein bisschen einige die Nase gerümpft und zu sagen, für uns ist das doch völlig normal hier. Was willst du eigentlich?
Also wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie das Anspruchsbedenken unter den Nürnberger, oder? Wir sind hier die Franken, wir sind die Nummer 1 und es kommt so ein dahergelaufener Bauer aus den Tausend. Was will der denn hier erreichen?
Genau. Und dann läuft es natürlich sportlich am Anfang nicht gleich wirklich und dann prasselt natürlich alles auf dich ein. Und er hat dann Gott sei Dank den Turnaround geschafft. Ich glaube, für mich war ja das der Turnaround des Spiels gegen Fürth eigentlich, das wir verloren haben, aber wo man eigentlich erstmal auf dem Platz gesehen hat, ok, jetzt hat sich was verändert. Wir sind eigentlich hier schon die bessere Mannschaft. Das war, sage ich jetzt nicht, weil es das Derby gegen Fürth war und weil wir es verloren haben, sondern weil es auch gefühlt wirklich so war. Wir haben es dann unglücklich verloren durch so einen abgefälschten Schuss. Aber das war, fand ich schon, der Turnaround. Wenn er jetzt danach im Bielefeld auch verloren hätte, ich glaube, dann wäre es eng für ihn geworden, aber da haben wir dann gewonnen und da startet er ja dann eine Siegesserie.
Dann startet eine Siegesserie, aber wenn wir bei Alois Schwarz bleiben, dann können wir auch noch über das Rückspiel gegen Fürth sprechen. Das sollte nämlich dann sein letztes Spiel als Klubtrainer gewesen sein. Wieder eine Niederlage auswärts, sofern man davon auswärts sprechen möchte. 0 zu 1. Warum musste er dann letztlich gehen?
Ja, da ist natürlich einiges zusammengekommen. Ich glaube, natürlich war der Abgang von Guido Buchstaller ein Problem, muss man ganz klar sagen.
Aber daran hat er ja keine Schuldigkeit, oder?
Daran hat er keine Schuldigkeit, aber er hat es natürlich immer wieder. Ich sage immer, er hatte natürlich recht in dem, was er sagte, aber er hat es natürlich immer nach den schlechten Spielen oder nach den Niederlagen immer wieder aufs Tablo gebracht, was vielen Leuten auf den Keks gegangen ist. Ja, wir wissen, Guido Buchstaller ist weg, aber wir können jetzt auch nichts dran ändern. Wir müssen jetzt das Beste daraus machen. Aber er hat es halt immer wieder nach vorne angeführt und hat immer wieder gesagt, hey, wir haben die ganze Offensive jetzt innerhalb von einem Jahr. Ich meine, vorher, da war er zwar noch nicht da, aber im letzten Winter ging dann Schöpf, im Sommer ging Füllkrug und jetzt in der aktuellen Winterpause ging dann Burgstaller. Damit hast du natürlich eine geballte Offensivkraft verkauft und das hat er immer wieder angeführt und immer wieder gebetsmühlenartig als Argument vorgebracht und nichts anderes. Und das ging vielen Leuten auf den berühmten Sack, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Was anderes, was ich noch ein bisschen weiß, ist, dass es wohl in der Winterpause irgendeinen Bruch gab zwischen Trainer und Mannschaft. Also da stimmte die Chemie dann auch nicht mehr. Das hatten wir dann auch in dem Viertelspiel, in diesem wirklich desolaten Spiel gegen Kräuter Fürth gesehen. Und es musste die Reißleine da gezogen werden. Viele sprachen davon in Nürnberg. Ja, man befindet sich im freien Fall, weil man letzter der Rückrundentabelle war. Ich sah das jetzt nicht so ganz extrem, weil wir eigentlich bloß drei Punkte weg waren vom Platz 6 oder so. Also es war nicht ganz so dramatisch, wie viele gezeichnet haben. Aber wenn man so das Gesamtbild dann nimmt, du hast einen Trainer, der bei den Fans überhaupt nicht beliebt ist. Das wurde immer schlimmer. Gegen Fürth das Derby nochmal, da ist die Stimmung nochmal komplett gekippt. Und du hast natürlich auch interne Probleme. Das hat man dann auch an den Interviews nach dem Spiel von den Spielern, hat man dann zwischen den Zeilen schon hören können, dass es da nicht so funktioniert zwischen Trainer und Mannschaft. Dann war es folgerichtig, dass man die Reißleine zieht.
Und Nachfolger wurde dann Michael Kölner, vorher Leiter des Nachwuchsleistungszentrums und Chef-Trainer der U21. Wenn wir jetzt bei Schwarz darüber sprechen, dass das viel so weiche Faktoren waren, also vor allem Außendarstellung, wie man kommuniziert, nach innen und nach außen, sind das auch die wesentlichen Punkte, die Kölner dann anders gemacht hat oder spielt der Club seitdem auch anders?
Er spielt auch anders. Was man ihm immer natürlich auch vorgeworfen hat, dass Schwarz diesen typischen Zweitliga-Fußball gespielt hat, also quasi lange Bälle und dann auf zweite Bälle hoffen, was ich ihm gar nicht so vorwerfen kann, weil René Weiler hat das genau so gemacht. Und da hat sich keiner drüber beschwert, vielleicht auch unter anderem, weil Weiler da viele Spiele so gewonnen hat. Aber für mich ist es so, lange Bälle auf zweite Bälle hoffen und dann schauen, dass man vor das Tor kommt. Das ist für mich so ein typischer Zweitliga-Fußball. Das spielen viele. Das haben ihm aber auch viele vorgeworfen, vielleicht auch, weil es unter anderem dann ohne die Du Borgstaller nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Das hat Kölner sicherlich anders gemacht. Er versucht es eher, über kurze, flache Pässe vor das Tor zu kommen. Ist natürlich auch in der Außendarstellung komplett anders. Ist auch ein bisschen extrovertierter, würde ich sagen. Er redet viel, sehr, sehr viel. Kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen Urik rüber mit seinem Oberpfälzer Dialekt. Das macht ihn auch ein Stück weit sympathisch, natürlich.
Das hören die Oberpfälzer jetzt gerne, sagt nicht jeder, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, aber es macht ihn authentisch. Es macht ihn authentisch. Und er redet sehr viel und gerne über Fußball. Viele hören ihm auch gerne zu. Und deswegen ist er vielleicht auch deutlich beliebter als Alois Schwarz.
Wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht erzählt habe, dann hattet ihr in den letzten 5 Jahren 10 Trainer. Davon hätte ich dir 4 nennen können. Und ich würde mich als fußballinteressierten Menschen bezeichnen. Okay, 5 hätte ich vielleicht noch zusammengebracht. Wir können jetzt nicht bei jedem da ins Detail gehen. Aber woran liegt denn das? Dass der Club da so ist wie der HSV, nur ohne Geld. Wie ein armer HSV ist der Verein. Aufgeregtes Umfeld, Fanbasis ist da, aber auch nicht unkritisch gegenüber dem Verein und unglaublich hoher Trainerverschleiß.
Ja, wobei der Trainerverschleiß jetzt ja eigentlich besser werden sollte unter Andreas Bornemann.
Ja, aber du merkst den Konjunktiv ja, oder? Klar, das sagt der HSV dir auch. Wir dachten mit Bruno Labbadia haben wir unseren Jahrhundert-Trainer gefunden.
Also Bornemann sagte bei seinem Amtsantritt auf der ersten Jahreshauptversammlung, hat genau das angeführt, was du gesagt hast, diese vielen Trainer in den letzten Jahren, dass das nicht sein kann und dass man so keine Stabilität reinbringt. Jetzt musste er selber erst mal seinen Trainer entlassen. Gut, dass jetzt Weiler nach Anderlecht gegangen ist, da kann er nichts dafür. Das ist halt so, das ist ja keine Trainerentlassung. Wir hätten Weiler gerne behalten, sieht man ja, was er in Anderlecht erreicht hat. Ist ja ja Meister geworden und war ziemlich weit in der Europa League mit dabei. Bei Alois Schwarz blieb ihm, glaube ich, keine andere Möglichkeit, ihn zu entlassen, weil, wie ich jetzt schon angeführt habe, in dem Spiel gegen Kräuter-Fürth, da ist die Stimmung so dermaßen gekippt. Und wenn du dann auch noch interne Probleme hast, dann bleibt dir da keine andere Möglichkeit. Ich hoffe jetzt, dass es mit Kölner besser klappt, obwohl ich da auch schon einer zu den Skeptikern gehörenden Nürnberg, weil es jetzt natürlich auch so war, dass Kölner vieles angekündigt hat, was da nicht eingetreten ist. Und jetzt auch schon wieder vom Aufstieg spricht, dass man in dem Dunstkreis der Aufsteiger mitspielt.
Ihr seid wirklich der HSV für Amel.
Wobei es da jetzt nicht von den Fans kommt. Ich glaube, da sind die Fans mittlerweile schon besser eingenordet. Ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt, warum es nach der Saison, nach den letzten Spielen, wie man da draufkommen kann, dass man nächstes Jahr darum den Aufstieg mitspielen könnte. Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht weiß ich von irgendwelchen Transfers, die noch anstehen, aber aktuell sehe ich das nicht. Und da ist jetzt auch schon die Stimmung so ein bisschen geteilt. Es gibt natürlich viele, die finden es gut, was Kölner sagt, die hängen an seinen Lippen. Die finden das toll. Die andere Hälfte ist dann so ähnlich kritisch wie ich. Sie sagt, wenn ich jetzt ankündige, ich hole in den letzten zwei Spielen 6 Punkte und hole da 0 Punkte und spiele auch noch schlecht dabei, dann kann irgendwas nicht stimmen. Noch dazu geht man ein hohes Risiko ein, weil man den NLZ-Leiter, den man erst kurz ein Jahr zuvor eingestellt hat, auf dem viele Hoffnungen lagen, der auch viel Lob bekommen hat, den setzt man jetzt quasi auf diesen Schleuderschuhl des Cheftrainers, wo man dann Gefahr läuft, dass man vielleicht im Herbst dann seinen NLZ-Leiter und Cheftrainer verliert. Es bleibt spannend in Nürnberg. Ich bin gespannt, wie das nächste Jahr läuft.
Das ist ja die Scheiße im Fußball. In jedem normalen Wirtschaftsunternehmen würdest du einen nach oben befördern, in der Hoffnung, es funktioniert, weil er in seiner alten Stelle extrem gute Arbeit geliefert hat. Dann klappt das nicht. Dann würdest du normalerweise sagen, ok, pass auf, dann mach einfach weiter dein altes Aufgabengebiet, das hast du ja super gemacht, oder suchen wir ein neues für dich. Das kannst du im Fußball nicht machen. Wenn der bei euch unten durch ist, dann ist der weg.
Dann ist er nicht noch. Auch wenn man es ihm anbieten würde, würde er es auch nicht machen.
Ich fand den Satz sehr schön. Es wird spannend bleiben beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Da möchte ich dir vollumfänglich zustimmen. Ich komme ja aus der Region, habe ganz viele alte Kindheitsfreunde, die Club-Fans sind. Es ist eigentlich ein Wunder, dass ich nicht auch Nürnberger geworden bin. Schade eigentlich. Ich weiß nicht. Ich lebe ganz gut in meinem anderen Leben. Ich bin eigentlich ganz froh. Vor allem weiß ich ja, dass man von seinem Verein nicht wegkommt. Ich habe es mir ja auch nicht ausgesucht. Langweilig wird es definitiv nicht werden. Aber da kann man ja auch nur Club-Fans United verfolgen. Dann wird einem das schon sehr eindrücklich klar. Abschließend sage ich mal noch, ich weiß jetzt schon, was die Erwartungshaltung ist, die der Trainer schürt auf die Klar-Nichts-Anderes-Hätt-ich-erwartet-beim-FCN. Was ist denn so deine Erwartung in die kommende Saison? Was glaubst du, sind jetzt die wichtigen Schritte, die passieren müssen, damit man in etwas ruhigere Fahrwässer gerät?
Also finanziell sind wir ja schon gut dabei, glaube ich. Also die Konsolidierung, die läuft. Wir haben uns auch die Lizenz bekommen, zwar mit Auflagen, aber die Auflagen haben wir ja schon erfüllt. Das ist alles im grünen Bereich. Wir haben natürlich da ein Päckchen zu tragen mit den Finanzen. Sebastian wird das vielleicht auch aus Kaiserslautern kennen. Wir sind aber gut dabei, glaube ich, das zu lösen. Bei uns steht ja auch die Ausgliederung an. Es ist jetzt aber alles noch nicht spruchreich. Wird das im September kommen? Nichts genau ist, weiß man nicht, wie das verlaufen wird. Was da nächstes Jahr drin ist, also ich glaube nicht. Aktuell Status Quo Stand heute. Ich weiß nicht, welche Transfers noch kommen und wie es läuft. Die 2. Liga ist auch immer eine Wundertüte. Aktuell sehe ich uns ähnlich wieder im Mittelfeld. Man muss natürlich aufpassen, wenn man so viele junge Spiele einbaut. Da muss man mit einrechnen, dass die Fehler machen, dass du da vielleicht auch mal ein Spiel verlierst, das du eigentlich nicht verlieren solltest. Aktuell sehe ich uns da im Mittelfeld, hat auch unser Finanzvorstand Meshke angekündigt, schon auf der jetzigen Lares Hauptversammlung, dass es Übergangsjahre geben wird, wo wir uns wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen durchwurschteln, bis wir dann komplett konsolidiert sind und bis man dann vielleicht mal wieder vom Aufstieg sprechen kann in Nürnberg. Das Potenzial haben wir, das ist klar, aber das Potenzial haben nicht bloß wir, das hat auch der FCK, es ist Lautern oder andere große Clubs. Dynamo Dresden hat sicherlich auch von seinem ganzen Umfeld und seinen Fans auch das Potenzial oder den Anspruch, irgendwann mal wieder erste Liga zu spielen. Deswegen muss ich auch wieder sagen, ich bin gespannt, wie es weiterläuft.
Ich glaube, diese gespannte Erwartungszeitung, die teilen wir uns hier alle. Dann gucken wir mal, was beim Club noch so passiert. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was beim FCK passiert ist, denn die liegen nur ein Tabell im Platz hinter dem 1. FC Nürnberg. Das wird euch alle weniger überraschen als mich. Der 1. FC Kaiserslautern mit 41 Punkten, 10 Siegen, 11 Unentschieden, 13 Niederlagen, nur 29 erzielten Toren bei aber auch nur 33 Kassierten. Sebastian, jetzt beginnt deine Zeit. Fühl mich mal durch die Saison. Was muss ich wissen zu Lautern in dieser Saison?
Es war eine sehr, sehr schwierige Saison. Es ist nicht übertrieben. Fakt, wenn man sagt, es war die zweitschlechteste der Vereinsgeschichte nach 2008, wo wir es am letzten Spieltag erst geschafft haben, nicht abzusteigen.
Aber wie hieß noch mal der Trainer? Das war doch, als es so geregnet hat.
Milan Sašić.
Ja, Milan Sašić. Das war mit eines der tollsten Field-Interviews, das in so einer Situation mal geführt wurde. Da sagt dann der Sport1-Reporter, ja und dann fing es ja auch noch an zu regnen. Da sagt er, ja, da sagen sie was. Fritz Walter. Ich habe es gleich gedacht. Ach, super.
Das war das viel zitierte Fritz Walter, bitte. Der ja sehr gerne bei Regen gespielt hat. Und das war in dem Moment. Ich war damals auch im Stadion. Dann fing es da an zu regnen. Und du hast dann wirklich so das Gefühl, es ist ein Zeichen von oben. Wir Fußballfans, wir glauben ja gerne mal an solche Sachen. Von daher. Aber diese Zeiten von damals sind ja schon länger rum. Und wir sind in einem neujährlichen Tief, sozusagen. Was eigentlich schon ziemlich bezeichnend ist für den Verlauf der Saison. Es war so, dass man nach einer durchwachsenen Saison davor mit Platz 10, mit wenig Euphorie im Umfeld, es noch mal irgendwie geschafft hat, so im Vorfeld, vor dem ersten Saisonspiel in dieser Saison noch mal so ein bisschen die Euphorie zu schüren. Man hat es geschafft, dass das Stadion beim ersten Heimspiel recht voll war, die Stimmung war ganz gut. Und dann wirst du direkt von Hannover mit 4-0 weggeklatscht. Und dann ist irgendwie quasi alles, was vorher war, an Euphorie und so, ist wieder im Arsch. Und dann kannst du quasi wieder bei 0 anfangen. Das war schon ein sehr, sehr, sehr schlechter Start. Und dazu kommt ein Kader, der nicht wirklich optimal zusammengestellt ist. Dazu kommt die wachsende Unzufriedenheit bei den Fans. Dazu kommt, dass sowohl ein Trainer als auch gerade aktuell der Sportdirektor von sich aus sagen, sie hören auf, weil es irgendwie im Umfeld nicht stimmt oder weil sie keine Perspektive sehen. Also da ist schon ein arg viel im Argen im Umfeld beim 1. FCK zu slautern. Und man fragt sich natürlich, wie soll das irgendwann wieder nach vorne gehen.
Ja, dann brauche ich dir die Frage nicht stellen, wenn du das selber auch ratlos bist. War denn die anfängliche Euphorie, auf welcher Grundlage stand die denn eigentlich? Also gab es irgendwelche großen Verpflichtungen, die ich nicht mitbekommen habe, von denen man dachte, die schlagen jetzt richtig granatenmäßig ein? Oder woher kamen die?
Die kamen daher, dass man sich als Fan wahrscheinlich gedacht hat, irgendwann muss es ja auch mal wieder besser werden. Weil es ist nun mal leider so, wie du es ja auch gesagt hast, der FCK ist mittlerweile eine gestandene Zweitligamannschaft. Was mal als einmalige Ausrutscher mit einem sehr, sehr schönen und viel gefeierten Meistertitel im Anschluss begonnen hat, ist mittlerweile nicht mal mehr ein Fahrstuhl geworden, sondern jetzt quasi eine etablierte Zweitligazugehörigkeit. Von daher, was hat die Euphorie geschürt? Es war auch nur eine vorsichtige Euphorie, aber es war einfach der Glaube oder die Hoffnung daran, dass es ja irgendwann doch mal wieder besser werden muss. Und dass irgendwie vielleicht auch die verpflichteten Spieler doch was reißen. Aber im Endeffekt ist man da relativ schnell wieder auf dem Boden der Tatsachen gelandet.
Und wie verlief die Saison jetzt sportlich? Du hast schon gesagt, gleich im ersten Spiel ein entspanntes 0-4 zu Hause gegen Hannover 96. Aber danach hat sie nicht aufgehört. Gott sei Dank letztlich sogar.
Nein, natürlich hat es danach nicht aufgehört. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das... Der Start war schon sehr, sehr, sehr schlecht, kann man so sagen. Hat schon bis zum sechsten Spieltag gedauert, bis mal ein Sieg kam. Und es ist einfach, wenn du dann gleich im ersten Spiel so auf die Fresse bekommst und diese langsam auch keimende Euphorie so gebremst wird und dann es so lange dauert, bis du das erste Erfolgserlebnis hast, dann ist es schon sehr, sehr schwierig, da irgendwie eine ordentliche Stimmung zu generieren für den Rest der Saison. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, also wenn man sich mal anschaut, was wir für eine Spielsysteme hatten in dieser Saison, wird man feststellen, dass wir gefühlt in jedem Spiel ein anderes hatten. Und das irgendwie... Ich glaube, jeder Spieler gefühlt überall mal gespielt hat. Bedingt natürlich auch durch den Trainerwechsel dann, aber es war einfach generell keine Konstanz vorhanden. Weder im System noch sonst irgendwie.
Was in sich ja auch wieder was Konstantes ist, keine Konstanz. Rhetorisches Stilmittel. Aber wenn du jetzt schon den Trainer ansprichst, Taifun Korkut geht Ende Dezember und Norbert Maier, der unter nicht den besten Umständen bei Darmstadt 98 entlassen wurde, fängt beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern an. Da habe ich mir verwundert, den Kopf gekratzt, aus zwei Gründen. Das eine ist, dass ich fand, dass Norbert Maier jetzt nicht gerade brilliert hat in seinem Amt bei Darmstadt und das andere ist aber vor allem, dass ich mir dachte, okay, wir haben eine Mannschaft, die für den Trainerteil von Korkut oder zumindest mit ihm zusammen eingestellt wurde. Ich weiß, welchen Fußball Korkut so grob spielen lassen möchte und ich weiß, was Norbert Maier so spielen lässt. Für mich hat das vorne und hinten nicht gepasst. Aber ich habe ja auch immer nur so den Blick von weiter weg, übersehe ich da was?
Es ist schwierig, es ist wirklich schwierig. Mein Eindruck von Korkut war am Anfang, dass es ziemlich gut passt. Er hat sich auch so, finde ich, gut präsentiert. Er hatte relativ viel auch mit ihm zu tun und hat da einen sehr unaufgeregten Job gemacht. Natürlich ist der Wechsel von Korkut auf Maier schwierig zu vergleichen, weil es zwei komplett unterschiedliche Trainertypen sind.
Das ist, als würdest du Tankert vor dem Spiel auftreten lassen und Helene Fischer in der Pause.
Das ist ein schöner Vergleich, auf alle Fälle. Das Einzige, was mir Hoffnung gemacht hat, ist, dass Norbert Maier schon gestandener Zweitligatrainer ist. Auch wenn er sich in Darmstadt nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert hat. Aber Erfahrung hat der Mann. In Kaiserslautern ist es auch so, man muss nicht schön spielen, man muss kämpfen. Ich glaube, Norbert Maier weiß, wie man seine Mannschaft so einstellt, dass sie auch kämpft. Aber es kommt eben darauf an, dass die Einstellung prinzipiell stimmt. Dann sind die Leute auf dem Betzenberg auch zufrieden. Der Pfälzer an sich ist eigentlich relativ einfach zufrieden zu stellen. Er erwartet keine großen fußballerischen Künste. Er erwartet nicht, dass Spieler geholt werden, die 85 Tore pro Saison schießen, sondern er erwartet, auf gut Deutsch gesagt, dass die Spieler, die auf dem Platz stehen, egal wo sie herkommen, sich den Arsch aufreißen. Und der Pfälzer an sich erwartet, dass er wenigstens ein, zwei Spieler im Kader hat, mit denen er sich identifizieren kann. Weil sie aus der Region kommen, weil sie sich über die Jugend etabliert haben im Verein, das wird halt auch immer schwieriger. Zumal der FCK ja auch aus finanzieller Sicht dazu gezwungen ist, eigentlich die Eigengewächse, die ordentlich spielen, die gut sind, zu verkaufen, wenn sich die Gelegenheit bietet, dafür nochmal ein bisschen Geld zu kassieren, weil man einfach für die Klammerkasse dieses Geld braucht. Von daher ist auch allein da deswegen die Konstanz, dass wir keine Konstanz haben, weil wir ständig einen Neuanfang haben, wir haben ständig einen Umbruch. Der Kader muss gefühlt quasi jede Saison komplett neu zusammengestellt werden, weil du nie in der Lage bist, die wenigen Spieler, die Leistungsträger sind, die konstant Leistung bringen, zu halten. Sondern du bist gezwungen, sie zu verkaufen oder oft sogar ablösefrei ziehen zu lassen, weil die Verträge ebenso sind. Und dann stehst du am Ende da und musst halt darauf hoffen, dass der Sportdirektor irgendwie eine Mannschaft zusammenwürfelt, die einigermaßen homogen ist, was aber leider in den letzten Jahren nicht so gut gelungen ist.
Noch ein Wort zu Norbert Maier. Ich muss dir denn echt eine Lanze für ihn brechen, obwohl ich es ungern tue und eigentlich sehr gerne Witze über ihn mache. Er hat einen Damenstaat, der nicht so performt, wie man erwartet hat, hat aber vorher in Bielefeld 2-3 Jahre gute Arbeit abgeliefert. Also es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt... Also wenn man die Leistung Maier... Ich habe einen Echo, deswegen bin ich irritiert... .definieren möchte oder beurteilen möchte, dann muss man halt auch die Bielefeld-Zeit dazu nehmen und nicht nur die in Darmstadt.
Ja, absolut. Ich denke auch, wie gesagt, an sich, dass Norbert Maier ein gestandener Trainer ist, dass er Erfahrung hat. Er ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der, der verpflichtet wird und du denkst, okay, in zwei Jahren spielen wir Champions League, aber an sich auf jeden Fall ein solider Trainer für die Zweite Liga. Es ist halt, ich glaube, dass einfach die alles, was drumherum ist, ich glaube, dass es einfach unglaublich schwer ist im Moment, ordentliche Arbeit in Kaiserslautern zu machen, weil einfach so viel Unruhe da ist, die Fans mega unzufrieden sind, es kein Geld da ist und einfach, ja, es ist einfach unglaublich schwierig. Und das Grundproblem in Kaiserslautern ist, man muss es leider so sagen, aber es ist bei vielen nicht angekommen, wo der FCK mittlerweile eigentlich steht. Nämlich genau da, wo Max ihn für sich selber auch eingeordnet hat, nämlich als etablierter, leider etablierter Zweitligist. Das heißt, bei vielen Leuten ist im Kopf noch nicht angekommen, dass der FCK im Moment einfach, leider Gottes, keine größere Rolle spielen kann. Ja, immer noch nicht angekommen. Ein gutes Beispiel ist zum Beispiel auch, das hat nicht nur damit zu tun, sondern auch generell mit der spielerischen Einschätzung, Julian Polersbeck, der Torwart, wie gesagt, wird mit dem Hamburger SV in Verbindung gebracht. Da wird von um die 3 Millionen gesprochen als Ablöse. Und viele FCK-Fans, bei Twitter, Facebook, wo auch immer, regen sich da tierisch drüber auf, warum denn dann nur 3 Millionen Euro gezahlt werden würden, wenn der dann wechselt. Das wäre ja viel zu wenig. Da man müsste also an FCK-Stelle unter 5, 6 Millionen, dürfte man den auf gar keinen Fall gehen lassen. Wo ich mir dann denke, woher kommt dieser Anspruch? Das hat natürlich aber auch, also man muss ja auch mal sehen, Julian Polersbeck ist ein super Torwart, mit ganz viel Potenzial, der sich ja auch noch einen guten Sprung nach vorne machen wird. Das ist ja wirklich, das ist wirklich die einzige Konstanz, die es in Kaisersautern gibt, die gute Torwart-Schule von Gary Ehrmann, der ja wirklich mit Weidenfeller Wiese und so weiter wirklich einige tolle Torhüter hervorgebracht hat und auch immer wieder es schafft, aus dem Nachwuchs gute Torhüter rauszubringen. Aber Julian Polersbeck hat jetzt seine erste Saison als Stammtorhüter gespielt, im bezahlten Fußball. Und dass ein solcher Spieler dann nach einer Saison als Stammkeeper für 3 Millionen aus der 2. Liga in die 1. Liga zum HSV wechseln kann, also da muss man, denke ich, auch mal zufrieden mit sein. Also ich weiß nicht, woher der Anspruch kommt zu sagen, wir brauchen doch viel mehr Geld für den Jungen. Der ist gut, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass er der Übertorwart ist. Wie gesagt, ich will das gar nicht schmälern. Seine Leistung hat er gut gemacht. Es ist ja auch gar nicht so einfach, gerade als junger Torwart in so ein unruhiges Umfeld reinzukommen und sich dann dazu beweisen. Aber ich denke, wenn irgendwas einigermaßen gepasst hat, war es die Defensive, die zwei wenigsten Gegentore, was natürlich auch zu einem guten Teil an ihm lag.
Also ich kann da dem Sebastian nur zustimmen. Also wir haben in Nürnberg ein genau und ähnliches Problem. Ich glaube, ich sage immer so, wir sind da so gefangen in unserer eigenen Tradition. Dieser großartige 1. FC Nürnberg, dieser ruhmreiche 1. FC Nürnberg mit seinen neun Meisterschaften und vier Pokalsiegen, sowas zehren die Fans und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum in Kaiserslautern oder auch in Nürnberg, warum da die Vereinsführung nicht mal ein bisschen kommunikativ entgegenwirkt, dass man einfach mal sagt, hey Leute, wir sind aktuell bloß Zweitligist und nicht mehr. Und momentan ist finanziell auch mehr nicht drin. Ich war letztes Jahr wieder auf der Jahreshauptversammlung und das ist das Erste, was von den Vereinsverantwortlichen kommt. Was ich höre ist, ja dieser Verein gehört in die 1. Bundesliga. Dieser Verein, wir müssen noch eigentlich, eigentlich, wir gehören gar nicht hier in diese 2. Liga, wir sind doch eigentlich 1. Bundesliga. Und damit baust du so einen unheiligen Druck auf und auch eine Erwartungshaltung bei den Fans, dass sobald es mal schlecht läuft in der 2. Liga, alle Leute auf die Paragaten gehen und du Unruhe hast. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum man da als Vereinsführung nicht mal auch über einen langen Zeitraum, über einen längeren Zeitraum kommunikativ auf die Fans zugeht und ihnen mal erklärt, passt auf Leute, das ist Status Quo und mehr ist momentan nicht drin.
Das ist ganz einfach. Die Vereinsführung hat Angst davor, dass die Leute dann so enttäuscht sind, dass irgendwie gar keiner mehr kommt.
Ja, das passiert doch dann so und so, wenn du nicht erfolgreich bist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Oder wenn du unter den Erwartungen, in Anführungsprechen, spielst, dann.
Also in Lautern ist es so, dass sie damit vorsichtiger geworden sind, aber es fällt natürlich trotzdem immer mal wieder das Wort erste Liga. Also sie haben natürlich jetzt auch vor dieser Saison als Ziel ausgegeben einstelliger Tabellenplatz. Auch dieses Ziel haben sie mal wieder nicht erreicht, aber auf lange Sicht gesehen sagt jeder, auch jeder, der neu vorgestellt wird, die Vereinsführung ist ja auch neu angetreten vor der Saison, sagt irgendwie jeder, ja, auf lange Sicht gesehen gehört der 1. FC Kaiserslautern in die 1. Bundesliga.
Kenn ich.
Ja, und so ist das bei vielen Traditionsvereinen, aber es ist nun mal so, die Plätze in der 1. Liga wären nicht mehr. Dafür aber die Konkurrenz wird umso größer, auch kleinere Vereine, die einfach bessere Mittel haben. Und von daher, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob man sich auf lange Sicht gesehen damit abfinden muss, dass man einfach in 2.
Ligas ist.
Eben, die Plätze werden ja eher weniger, weil halt einfach Teams wie, ihr habt jetzt Hoffenheim vorbei marschieren sehen, ihr habt Leipzig vorbei marschieren sehen, wer weiß, ob da noch mal von hinten einer vorbeizieht. Und das sind alles Vereine, die eben, das haben wir ganz am Anfang schon besprochen, die haben die finanziellen Mittel, dass wenn denen mal das Unglück-Abstieg passiert, haben die eine komplett andere Ausgangsbasis, eine wirtschaftliche Ausgangsbasis, um direkt wieder aufzusteigen. Das heißt, die Plätze in der ersten Liga sind für Teams wie Nürnberg, Lautern, Bochum, Fürth, für diese ganze Reihe auch Berlin, St. Pauli, Braunschweig. Es sind weniger verfügbare Plätze. Das hört sich so ein bisschen paradox an, weil es sind ja trotzdem pro Jahr zwei, die aufsteigen und zwei, die absteigen, plus noch eine Relegation, der dann vollkommen überraschend der 1. Liga sich durchsetzen kann. Aber de facto ist es, glaube ich, so. Und ich glaube, man muss sich tatsächlich dann zufriedengeben. Das ist natürlich schwierig. Du wirst dich wahrscheinlich nie damit zufriedengeben können, zu sagen, unser Platz ist die 2. Liga. Weil du willst ja in irgendetwas, einen sportlichen Wettbewerb, besteht ja darin, dass du immer etwas erreichen möchtest in diesem sportlichen Wettbewerb. Sonst kannst du es auch gleich lassen. Deswegen musst du natürlich immer auch die Perspektive haben. Wir wollen natürlich, wir treten jetzt hier schon 34 Spieltage an, um Erfolg zu haben. Und der Erfolg wäre in dem Fall ein Aufstieg. Aber der Aufstieg ist die Ausnahme von der Regel. Und das ist halt, glaube ich, auch schwierig zu vermitteln.
Freiburg hat mal vor Jahren definiert, wir gehören zu den besten 21 Vereinen Deutschlands. Also zwar die Liga ist okay, aber eigentlich sehen wir uns in der ersten Liga. Vielleicht müssen Vereine wie Lautern und Nürnberg das auch so akzeptieren. Wir gehören zu den Top-30-Vereinen Deutschlands. Und dass man halt dieses Anspruch denken muss. Nicht wir gehören in die erste Liga, sondern wir gehören zu den Top-25. Dass man sie halt so definiert.
Absolut. Zumal man sich ja auch mal bewusst machen muss, sollte man mal einen Ausrutscher nach oben haben und aufsteigen, wie schwer das eigentlich ist, dann auch oben drin zu bleiben. Auf lange Sicht gesehen.
Genau, das ist genau der Punkt. Es ist echt eine verzwickte Situation. Auch keine ganz schöne Situation, ehrlich gesagt. Für eigentlich alle Beteiligten. Ich finde es jetzt auch aus Sicht der ersten Liga, ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht so geil, aber da kommt jetzt auch nochmal viel persönliche Meinung mit rein. Wir haben ja über Besucherzahlen, Fan-Potenzial usw. auch gesprochen, aber das macht es halt schwierig.
Wir müssen eine Sache, würde ich ganz gerne noch sagen, zum FCK, weil ich glaube, du willst wahrscheinlich auch weiterziehen, sozusagen. Ja, müssen wir natürlich. Die Vorzeichen für die kommende Saison sind jetzt natürlich auch wieder denkbar schlecht, weil der Sportdirektor in der ungünstigsten Phase der Saison, nämlich der Transferperiode, hingeschmissen hat, bzw. dabei ist hinzuschmeißen und gerade gesagt hat, er macht jetzt bis Ende des Monats noch weiter, hört dann aber auf. Das ist natürlich, wenn es dann so schon wieder losgeht, gerade in der Phase, wo es darum geht, die richtigen Spieler für die kommende Saison zu verpflichten, das ist natürlich denkbar schlecht. Also man weiß jetzt nicht, wie das weitergehen soll, oder man fragt sich auch einen Spieler, der Verhandlungen mit ihm geführt hat oder auch noch führt, wechselt der dann wirklich zum FCK oder denkt, dass ich, wenn der Sportdirektor, der jetzt gerade noch mit mir verhandelt in ein paar Wochen, eh weg ist, der wird auch seine Gründe haben, soll ich dann wirklich zu dem Verein gehen, bei dem so viel Unruhe herrscht? Also es ist schwierig.
Ja, definitiv, dem kann man nicht widersprechen. Also der FCK auf Tabellenplatz 13. Ich finde, wir haben da eine ganz interessante Diskussion darüber geführt. Und jetzt müssen wir aber in der Tat weitergehen, weil uns auf uns wartet ja noch das zeittechnische Damos-Clash-Wert 1860 München, Leute. Das rechne ich gerade immer noch so ein bisschen ein, weil da kommen wir nicht in 5 Minuten drüber. Erzgebirge Aue, vielleicht klappt es da aber eher. Aue auch als Aufsteiger, die Klasse gehalten mit 39 Punkten, 3 Punkte Vorsprung letztlich vor 60. Ich habe es schon vorhin angesprochen, da gab es einen Auswärtssieg in Düsseldorf, der noch ganz wichtig war. Was können wir über Aue sagen, Stefan?
Dass sie zum richtigen Zeitpunkt den Trainer gewechselt haben und den anscheinend mit Ted Desco, der glaube ich auch in Nürnberg im Gespräch war, aber der damals schon dann bei Aue quasi zugesagt hatte, da haben sie alles richtig gemacht. Ted Desco hat quasi die da aus dem Abstiegssumpf rausgeholt. Also gefühlt, ich habe jetzt Aue auch nicht intensiv beobachtet, aber ich habe gesehen, seitdem Ted Desco da war, haben die ihre Spiele gewonnen und sind da sukzessive aus der Abstiegszone rausgekommen.
Also hat wesentlich mit dem Trainer zu tun, wurde ja auch schon gehandelt oder wird auch noch gehandelt. Bei Erstligisten, außerdem neue Stadion, also gerade im Bau befindlich, ehrlich gesagt mag ich das immer, wenn in Stadien gespielt wird, bei denen eine Tribüne schon fertig ist und eine andere noch nicht. Das ist, glaube ich, für den Verein, bei dem das gerade so ist, nicht so schön wie für mich als Zuschauer. Irgendwie waren das auch witzige Bilder, dass da schon Teile der Geraden stehen, aber logischerweise noch keine Fans drauf. Und da gibt es noch den alten Gäste-Block, auch noch in der alten Entfernung zum Spielfeld. Fand ich irgendwie putzig. Und scheint auch finanziell alles hinzuhauen, was, glaube ich, nicht so selbstverständlich ist, auch bei einem Stadionbau heutzutage. Was können wir über den Trainer hinaus noch sagen, Sebastian?
Dass der FCK prinzipiell dort nichts reißt.
Wäre es da nicht besser, nach dem Ausschlussverfahren zu gehen und zu sagen, wo reißt der FCK prinzipiell was?
Das stimmt. Ich habe auch wirklich Respekt davor, was in Aue geleistet wird. Start nicht so gut. Aber ich sage mal, Aue ist für mich auch wirklich eine der Mannschaften, so eine typische Zweitligamannschaft. Die schaffen das auch irgendwie immer wieder, da eine Rolle zu spielen, wenn auch keine große. Aber Aue ist irgendwie auch ein sympathischer, kleiner Verein.
Ja, in der Tat, das vergisst man fast so ein bisschen. Wenn wir zurückgehen bis in die Saison 2003, 2004, das heißt, das sind jetzt 13 Jahre, dann haben wir da 10 Zweitligajahre und 3 Drittligajahre. Also genau das, was du gesagt hast. Eigentlich eine Zweitligamannschaft mit unterschiedlichem Erfolg. Die letzten Jahre war es immer eher knapp nach unten hin. Einmal ja auch mit dem Abstieg und dann dem sofortigen Wiederaufstieg. Und es gab aber auch schon Zeiten, in denen man sich im Mittelfeld etabliert hatte. Interessanter Verein mit dem schön gelegenen Stadion. Sowas mag ich. Und ich glaube, davon ist auch gar nicht der Weg so weit zur Arminia Bielefeld. Die würde ich auch, Stefan, als so etablierte Zweitligamannschaft bezeichnen.
Ja, auch so eine Mannschaft, die zwischen 2. und 3. Liga wandelt. Am Ende haben sie auch das Ruder knapp noch rumbekommen. Respekt dafür. Sah jetzt lange Zeit auch nicht so aus. Ich dachte auch, dass Bielefeld eigentlich ein sicherer Absteiger ist. Haben sie aber dann glücklicherweise geschafft, wegen den anderen Mannschaften dahinter, über die wir noch reden werden. Das Highlight war natürlich das Überraschendste für mich war dieses 6 zu 0 gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Das hätte, glaube ich, keiner erwartet. Das hat sie, glaube ich, auch dann am Ende gerettet. Jürgen Gramm, der war da Trainer, der war auch mal beim Club. Du hast dir vergessen, mir eine Vorlage zu geben. Ansonsten kann ich nicht viel über Bielefeld sagen.
Wir müssen über die Kabinen ansprechen.
Ach ja, da gab es ein Video.
Das Video war grandios.
Kann aber auch nach hinten losgehen, finde ich irgendwie. Also, ja, es ist ja alles gut gegangen und so die grundsätzliche Message kämpft nicht für die 25.000 da draußen, sondern für eure Frauen und für eure Kinder und für eure Freunde. Das triggert, glaube ich, schon auch noch mal bei manchen. Aber wenn du das Ding gegen Braunschweig für dies Jahr da um den direkten Aufstieg noch ging, du verlierst es halt nur zwei, dann hast du es wirklich vorher auf der Tribüne den Spielerfrauen noch gezeigt, dann denken die sich auch, naja, hat dir anscheinend so viel gebracht.
Was man sich bei Bielefeld auch mal geben muss, ist, dass die die ersten zehn Spiele nicht gewonnen haben. Das hat bis zum 11. Spieltag gedauert, bis sie drei Punkte geholt haben. Also das ist auch schon mega frustrierend.
Ja, und dafür, wie sie aus der Saison rausgegangen sind, seit dem 21. Spieltag nur zwei Niederlagen. Und dann vier Siege und der Rest waren alles unentzündlich.
Die da auch einen Trainerwechsel? Die hatten doch auch einen Trainerwechsel da? Ja. War das vielleicht auch zu der Zeit, dass die vielleicht auch den Trainerwechsel zum richtigen Zeitpunkt gemacht haben?
Das hingen zeitlich damit zusammen und peinlicherweise fallen mir jetzt gerade sämtliche Namen nicht ein. Von Jürgen Kramny war Trainer, das hast du schon angesprochen, aber nur genau bis zum März. Dann gab es eine Interim-Zeit mit Carsten Rump. Und Jeff Seibene, um Gottes Willen, das war jetzt peinlich. Sorry, in der Phase war ich aber auch wirklich schon sehr auf die 1. Liga. Also Jeff Seibene, das sprechen wir jetzt einfach mal aus, Seibene, wenn er aus Luxemburg kommt, ist seitdem Trainer, seit dem 20. März. Und jetzt springe ich noch mal kurz zurück in den Bereich der Tabelle und dann das Spielplan, und dann sehe ich ja seitdem nur noch eine Niederlage, nämlich gegen den VfB zu Hause 2 zu 3. Und das war ja auch wieder eins dieser berühmten VfB-Spiele, Enzo.
Der Kramli wird auch nicht mehr erfolgreicher Trainer. Wenn jetzt Bielefeld abgestiegen wäre, wäre er mit drei Vereinen in zwei Jahren abgestiegen. Er war ja VfB-Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, Profis abgestiegen, beide. Bielefeld wäre dann auch noch abgestiegen.
Ja, er läuft nicht so wirklich bei ihm, ja. Das könnte eher schwierig werden. Habt ihr sonst noch irgendwelche prägende Erinnerungen an Bielefeld in dieser Saison? Ich finde, Bielefeld ist immer noch gut für spektakuläre Heimspiele, die sowohl gewonnen als auch verloren gehen. Das ist irgendwie sowas, was sich auch so durch die Historie von Bielefeld durchträgt, finde ich. Auswärts wahnsinnig schwach, auswärts nur 10 Punkte geholt, 31 Tore kassiert. Zeigt auch ganz gut, wo man den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat, nämlich zu Hause.
Ja, in Bielefeld haben wir unser erstes Spiel gewonnen. Das ist noch meine Erinnerung an Bielefeld. War auch ein wichtiges Spiel damals. Deswegen kann ich mich da gut dran erinnern, weil wenn wir das verloren hätten, ich glaube dann, wie ich schon vorhin sagte, dann wäre es da schon eng für Adolf Schwarz geworden.
Ich sehe schon, hier bei Bielefeld tiefer zu bohren, ist anscheinend recht fruchtlos.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht Bielefeld.
Ach, machen wir den alten Witz noch?
Ja, den musst du jetzt bringen.
Okay, den musstest du bringen. Was man aber noch sagen kann, das habe ich vorhin schon kurz angesprochen, 22 Tore nach Standards, das ist natürlich schon krass. Also das hilft dann schon sehr, muss man sagen, wenn man so viele Tore nach Standards macht. Auf Platz 2 in dieser Tabelle dann Braunschweig und Hannover mit 5 Toren weniger. Das ist schon echt ein Pfund bei insgesamt 50 erzierten Toren, 22 nach Standards. Die Hörer dürfen sich jetzt die Prozentzahl dazu ausrechnen. Okay, bevor wir hier weiter im Dunkeln fischen bei Arminia Bielefeld, ich merke mir zum nächsten Rasenfunk Royal XS sollte ich mir einen Bielefelder in die Runde holen. Können wir jetzt endlich über den Absteiger, aber vorher noch Relegationsteilnehmer, 1860 München sprechen, über den so viel gesprochen wird in diesen Tagen. Ich habe noch nie, und das ist jetzt nicht gelogen, ich habe noch nie so viele Anfragen von Hörerinnen und Hörern bekommen zu einer Sendung, die ich über 60 machen soll. Und das, obwohl ich schon im Dezember, als sie die Akkreditierung entzogen haben, einigen Medienvertretern einen Sonderkurspass gemacht habe mit der Überschrift Neues von 1860 München, da hatte ich noch nicht auf dem Schirm, dass das fast eine eigene Sendung werden könnte, wenn ich immer Neues von 1860 München erzählen wollte. Ihr als Beobachter des ganzen Elends, schon seit vielen Jahren, Sebastian, mit welchen Worten kann man das einordnen, was dabei 60 passiert ist?
Also, das tut mir so, so leid. Ich kenne auch einige 60 Fans. Ich glaube, wir haben auch einen gemeinsamen Bekannten aus unserer Spox-Vergangenheit, den du auch noch kennst, der sehr, sehr leidet und sogar den Spitznamen Löwe trägt.
Er trägt es aber mit Fassung.
Er trägt es mit Fassung, aber es tut mir so leid. Zwischen Lautern und 60 ist es auch ein bisschen speziell. Da gibt es eine sehr, sehr lang bestehende Fan-Freundschaft, die zwar auch ein bisschen eingeschlafen ist die vergangenen Jahre, aber man ist sich da doch relativ freundschaftlich verbunden. Und zu sehen, wie es da rapide bergab geht, zu sehen, wie es Leute gibt, die den Verein im Stich lassen, die sich wirklich, man muss es so drastisch sagen, verpissen, sobald das Schiff untergeht, wie es einen Investor gibt, der da wüten, schalten, walten kann, wie er will, kein Mensch den Typen irgendwie aufhält. Also es ist quasi, 60 ist so das Paradebeispiel davon, was man als Fan nicht möchte, was mit seinem Verein passiert. Genau das passiert gerade bei 1860 München. Und man weiß gar nicht, was man möchte. Auf der einen Seite ist es total schlimm, dass es mit der 3. Liga jetzt nicht klappt. Auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich, am besten ist es wahrscheinlich tatsächlich, wenn man irgendwie diesen Niesmaik rausbekommt als Investor und dann zur Not in der 4. oder 5. Liga einen kompletten Neustart macht, als dass man weiter mit diesem, ich muss es so sagen, mit diesem verrückten Typ weitermachen muss und dass das nicht gut gehen kann. Das ist eine absolute Vollkatastrophe. Der deutsche Profifußball wird 1860, seine Fans, zumindest ich werde das schmerzlich vermissen, weil 60, solange ich aktiv fußballgucke, immer dazugehört hat. Auch wenn jetzt in den letzten Jahren leider immer in der 2. Liga, aber 60 ist für mich wirklich auch einer der Inbegriffe eines Traditionsvereins. Es tut mir unfassbar leid für das, was da passiert. Aber es ist leider auch irgendwie die Quittung von ganz, ganz vielen Fehlentscheidungen, die da getroffen worden sind in den vergangenen Monaten und Jahren.
Und so richtig kann man sicher nicht sicher sein, ob dieses Sich-Lösen vom Investor auch tatsächlich klappen wird. Also wir nehmen jetzt auf am Samstag des Champions League-Finals. Das ist auch, glaube ich, eine Kategorie, in der viele Investoren oder in der der Investor noch denkt bei 60. Nur zur Einordnung, weil bei 60 sich so schnell Dinge verändern. Aber Ismail ist ja lange nicht so, dass er sagt, ja okay, gut, ist schiefgegangen, ist weg. Eher im Gegenteil, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Ismail wird das tun, was bisher andere, wie zum Beispiel Martin Kundt bei Hannover 96, immer nur angedroht haben, nämlich 50 plus einsmal vor den Europäischen Gerichtshof ziehen. Und dann dürfte das Ding eigentlich fallen. Diese sowieso schon ausgehöhlte Regel, die unter anderem ja auch deshalb ausgehöhlt werden konnte, weil zum Beispiel jemand wie Martin Kundt gesagt hat, ey Leute, wenn ihr mir einfach nicht zugesteht, dass ich bei Hannover 96 Entscheidungsbefugnis mitbekomme für mein Investment, dann gehe ich halt vor den EGH. Das droht jetzt Ismail an, weil er offenbar auch dachte, 50 plus eins gilt in der vierten Liga nicht mehr. Das ist, naja, Wikipedia gibt es anscheinend nicht in Jordanien.
Hab ich das nicht, aber gab es nicht bei Twitter irgendwie die Runde, dass es die 50 plus eins-Regel ersten Tag, bevor die Lizenz entzogen wurde, eingeführt wurde in der dritten Liga? Also irgendwie...
Es ist so, ab der vierten Liga ist es nicht mehr Lizenzierung und so weiter, fällt nicht mehr unter die DFL, sondern fällt unter die Landesverbände. Das heißt in dem Fall den Bayerischen Fußballverband. Und die hatten bisher immer ähnliche Regelungen wie 50 plus eins mit verankert. Aber diesen klaren Fakt, diesen enttrennenden Fakt, dass die Entscheidungsbefugnis darüber entscheidet, ob jemand gegen 50 plus eins verstößt oder nicht, den haben sie noch mal in einer deutlicheren Formulierung. Erst am Donnerstag tatsächlich in einem sogenannten Umlaufverfahren. Das ist, wenn du ganz, ganz schnell was in deine Satzung noch reinkriegen willst, reingenommen, damit sie da auch rechtlich nicht angreifbar sind. Die Auslegung war aber schon quasi vorher, wir wollen 50 plus eins auch im Bayerischen Fußballverband praktizieren. Sie waren sich bloß nicht sicher, ob es juristisch wasserdicht ist. So habe ich es jetzt verstanden, ehrlich gesagt. Aber klar, da freut sich jetzt Ismail auch nicht drüber. Aber das ist ja logisch. Aber ehrlich gesagt, meine Befürchtung ist eher, der Mann bringt das eh schon sehr wackelige und auch schon sehr ausgehütte 50 plus eins zum Kippen. Und dann könnte das in einem Horrorszenario dazu führen, dass wir halt solche Geschichten, wie wir es jetzt mit Ismail erlebt haben, das heißt jemand, der als Hauptqualifikation viel Geld hat und als Nebenqualifikation Fußball Sachverstand leider fehlt, dass solche Leute noch bei mehr Vereinen einsteigen und wir noch mehr solche Geschichten schreiben.
Ja, aber Max, wir haben doch jetzt in Deutschland die 50-plus-1-Regel, aber in anderen Ländern nicht, Italien, England, Spanien. Gibt es denn irgendeinen vergleichbaren, verrückten Fall? Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
In Italien passiert sowas ständig. In Italien gibt es ganz viele, ich kann die jetzt leider gar kein konkretes Beispiel nennen, aber es gibt ganz viele Beispiele in Italien, wo irgendein verrückter Investor irgendeinen Verein unterstützt hat und das total in die Hose gegangen ist.
Da ist in Italien die Sache noch ein bisschen anders. Da gab es ja auch Präsidenten, die den Verein gekauft haben, also auch nicht nur externe Investoren, sondern wirklich Präsidenten, die aus der gleichen Stadt kamen, die den Verein gegen die Wand geführt haben. Okay, das war ein schlechtes Beispiel, der stimmt.
Naja, und du hast ja auch in der Premier League zum Beispiel Vereine gehabt. Jetzt war das Brighton Albion, wo der thailändische Besitzer, glaube ich, gesagt hat, mein Lieblingstier sind Löwen oder Tiger. Genau, Tiger. Und deswegen, wir ändern jetzt sowohl das Wappen als auch die Vereinsfarbe. Hall City, genau, Entschuldigung. Und auch bei, ach Gott, das ist ärgerlich, das mit die ganzen Beispiele nicht einfallen. Aber du hast schon immer wieder solche Geschichten gehabt, wo du einfach immer wieder mitbekommst, die sehen das als ihr Spielzeug. Und dahinter muss auch gar nicht eine Fußballleidenschaft stehen, zwingendermaßen. Und die machen damit, was sie wollen. Und es kann sie halt einfach keiner aufhalten. Dann kann es dir halt einfach passieren, ich überspitze jetzt, aber dann kann es halt sein, dass der 1. FC Kaiserslautern in Zukunft in gelb-grün spielt. Und sie heißen jetzt irgendwie die Power Dynamites Kaiserslautern oder die Power Rangers Lautern. Es gibt keinen Teufel mehr als Maskottchen, sondern das ist eine Batterie, weil es irgendein chinesischer Batterienhersteller gekauft hat und so weiter und so fort. Und das einzige Problem ist einfach, es gibt keinen Halten, so wie es jetzt bei 60 ja eigentlich auch schon ist, weil die durch ihre finanzielle Misere in eine Situation gekommen sind, in der sie vollkommen zu 100 Prozent abhängig von Ismail Kwan. Nur deswegen kann er seine immer kruderen Dinge da oder Visionen durchsetzen, beziehungsweise er lässt jetzt den Verein letztlich vor die Hunde gehen, weil seine Forderungen aufgrund von 50 plus 1 nicht erfüllt werden, wo man nicht weiß, ob das gehalten werden kann. Und das kann man glaube ich schon sagen. Und dann kommt noch eine zweite Komponente mit dazu. Wenn du es einfacher machst, für Einzel-, für Privatleute in den Fußball reinzugehen, dann öffnest du die Türen für Leute, die ihr Geld mit all möglichen Tätigkeiten verdienen. Das hast du in anderen Bereichen des Fußballs schon. Lest euch das Football-Leaks-Buch von Raphael Buschmann durch. Da gibt es genügend Leute, die in mafiösen Strukturen sich ihr Geld verdient haben auf höchst dubiose Art und Weise. Man kann fast nicht davon ausgehen, dass da auch legale Euros mit dabei sind. Und die nutzen den Fußball, in dem Fall viel auch über Beraterkonstrukte und so weiter, für Geldwäsche und um zum einen auch noch Renditen zu erzählen, die absolut, die du sonst nirgendwo kriegst, weil da halt der Fußball auch gerade ein großes Problem hat. Aber das kommt auch noch mit dazu. Informiert euch mal über die neuen chinesischen Besitzer vom AC Milan. Das ist erschreckend. Und sowas kannst du einfach nicht mehr aufhalten, wenn du nicht so einen, ja derzeit schützt die Rechtsvorgabe die Vereine davor, sich an jemanden zu verkaufen, der vielleicht dann doch nicht den Hintergrund hat, den man gerne gehabt hätte. Und du kannst es einfach nicht mehr zurückdrehen. Das ist, glaube ich, das zugrunde liegende Problem. Du hast jetzt keine Chance und das sehen wir, finde ich, am Fall 1860 sehr gut. Also wenn jetzt nicht, wenn es wirklich diesen Weg geht und da jetzt dann gegen klagt und 50 plus 1 fällt, dann ich sehe dann keine Möglichkeit, wie sich 1860 von diesem Investor lösen kann, von dem jeder Medienfans, neutrale Fans, 60 Fans, jeder sagt, der muss weg, der ist schlecht für 60. Der tut diesem Verein unrecht. Und das ist ja das, wovor 50 plus 1 schützt.
Um das mal rechtlich einzuordnen, das heißt, der hat Anteile gekauft, müsste jetzt praktisch von 60 ausbezahlt werden, wenn sie den loswerden wollen, oder? Oder gehen in die private Insolvenz?
Es hängt damit zusammen, dass es eine KGAA gibt, also eine Kommandate-Gesellschaft auf Aktien, in der ist die Profi-Mannschaft von 60 München drin. Und es gibt den Verein 1860 München, den EV. Und 50 plus 1 sagt letztlich, die Entscheidungsbefugnis muss immer beim EV liegen. Es darf nicht ein einzelner Geldgeber, der da meistens eben in so einer KGAA liegt, weil ja die ganze Struktur von dem EV ist ja gemeinnützig und so weiter. Es darf nicht sein, dass ein Geldgeber die Entscheidungsbefugnis in allen Belangen hat, also sportlich und so weiter. Dazu gibt es aber auch schon Ausnahmeregeln, wie eben zum Beispiel Hopp in Hoffenheim, wie Kind in Hannover, wie die Werksclubs Wolfsburg und Leverkusen. Und darum geht es aber letztlich. Er möchte jetzt die volle Entscheidungsbefugnis haben. Er hat verschiedene Forderungen gestellt, die alle oder die zum großen Teil gegen 50 plus 1 verstoßen. Und die Möglichkeiten, die du dann hast, ist quasi die KGAA kann ja unabhängig vom Verein insolvent gehen. Dann ist die KGAA insolvent. Aber so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, bin jetzt aber, ich möchte es aber hier auch gleich sagen, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ich bin zu 100 Prozent im Thema drin, auch wenn ich es wirklich versuche. So wie ich es verstanden habe, liegen dann die Spielberechtigungen für die Amateur-Teams von 60, also für die nicht Profi-Teams, die liegen noch beim EV. Das heißt, wenn die KGAA insolvent geht, dann könnte man mit diesen anderen Spiellizenzen im Amateur-Fußball neu starten, was in dem Fall Regionalliga wäre, weil der Bayerische Fußballverband auch bereit wäre, sogar ein 19. Team die Regionalliga aufzunehmen, was nochmal ein ganz eigenes, cooles Thema ist. Aber darum geht es eigentlich gerade.
Ich glaube, es ist das Beste für 60.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass es das Beste für 60 nicht mehr gibt.
Ja, das wenigste Schlimme.
Mein Gefühl ist ehrlich gesagt, du musst dich, glaube ich, von diesem Verein verabschieden und 60 neu gründen. Das vielleicht urteile ich auch zu hart, aber ich habe auch viele 60 Freunde und im Grunde rede ich seit ein paar Tagen über nichts anderes mehr mit den Fußballbekannten, die ich so habe. Also vielleicht, hoffentlich male ich auch zu schwarz. Gönnt man ja keinem Verein. Also das ist ja fürchterlich, aber übel. Und wir haben jetzt überhaupt nicht über Sportliche gesprochen. Und irgendwie ist das aber auch gerechtfertigt. Ich meine, Ivica Olic verrät jetzt im Interview, als wir sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz hatten, wurden irgendwie ein Drittel der Spieler gesagt, mit euch planen wir nicht mehr, ihr müsst weg. Und die Spieler haben dann alle noch bis zum Ende gespielt in der Startelf.
Ah, Katastrophe.
Es ist wirklich, also dann ist es auch, ich meine letztlich sportlich absolut gerechtfertigter Abstieg. Mit hohen Ambitionen, mit Dreierkette und so weiter gestartet, aber es nie richtig auf den Platz bekommen, trotz vereinzelt guter Neuzugänge. Aber es war nie eine Mannschaft, die irgendwie in sich als Mannschaft agiert hat. Hinten raus ein furchtbareres Saisonfinish und dann halt auch in dieser Relegation gegen Jan Regensburg vollkommen verdient abgestiegen, also sportlich gesehen.
Da war ja auch überhaupt keine Mannschaft zu erkennen. Da waren ein paar ganz gute Einzelspieler und die haben ja auch teilweise echt Kohle ausgegeben ohne Ende für Spieler. Aber das ist auch mal wieder der Beweis dafür, dass du nicht einfach nur, klar Geld spielt eine ganz, ganz wichtige Rolle im Profifußball, aber es reicht eben nicht einfach nur, irgendwoher irgendeinen Spieler für viel Geld zu kaufen und den dann in diese Mannschaft zu stecken und zu hoffen, dass die Mannschaft dadurch gut wird. Sondern das war einfach, 60 war einfach eine Zusammenstellung aus vielen Einzelcharakteren, die zusammen auch nicht funktioniert haben.
Ich bin eher der Meinung, dass im deutschen Fußball außer Reifreundlich keiner wirklich mit richtig viel Geld umgehen kann, um was bei Null zu bauen. Also die ganzen Kunstvereine und so weiter, außer Reifreunde kriegt das keiner hin. In dem Fall wäre 60 eine Art Kunstverein. Also ein Verein, der auf einmal viel Geld zur Verfügung hat, um einzukaufen. Ähnlich wie der HSV mit den Kühenmillionen. So viel sportliche Intelligenz ist in Deutschland dann doch nicht vertreten. Also im Fußball, in Deutschlands Fußball.
Das war ja das Hauptproblem in München. Geld war ja da, aber sportlich Kompetenz war da Null da. Also ich glaube, die haben 60 Millionen in 5 Jahren verpulfert in der 2. Liga, was verdammt viel Geld ist. Und wenn man da jetzt die letzten 3 Jahre immer um den Abstieg rumspielt, ja am Ende hat man es nicht anders verdient.
Das ist halt beim HSV das ähnliche Prinzip. Da ist die Kohle da, aber wenn du keinen hast, der das ordentlich unters Volk bringt, also einen richtigen Spieler investiert, dann bringt es dir halt auch nichts.
Das stimmt allerdings. Ich glaube, auch mit Blick auf die Uhr, wir müssen irgendwie versuchen, das Thema dicht zu machen. Es wird auch im Rasenfunk noch was geben. Ich weiß noch nicht wann, aber irgendwann gibt es da auch nochmal was Neues zu. Wir haben noch zwei Teams, über die wir sprechen müssen, die jetzt ein bisschen kürzer abgehandelt werden müssen. Leider sorry an die Fans derjenigen Vereine, die Würzburger Kickers. Wir haben es vorhin schon kurz erwähnt. Als Aufsteiger in die Saison furios gestartet und dann aber irgendwann, als hättest du den Stecker gezogen, Stefan, nix mehr auf die Kette gebracht und jetzt dann auch Tabellenplatz 17. Wenn man einfach nur auf die Endtabelle guckt, sagt man sich, na gut, Aufsteiger, der es nicht schafft, das hat es immer schon mal gegeben. Aber im Nachhinein trotzdem schon sehr bitter, wie das abgelaufen ist, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, die haben kein Spiel in der Rückrunde gewonnen. Ich glaube, alle verloren oder unentschieden gespielt. Ja, es sind natürlich euphorisch gestartet. Manchmal ist es ja so, ähnlich wie Dynamo Dresden. Du kommst mit dem Schwung, mit dem Aufstieg aus der 3. und 2. Liga. Da ist auch der Abstand nicht so groß, da ist der Qualitätsunterschied nicht so groß. Da kannst du schon was reißen, wenn du da mit einer gewissen Euphorie kommst. Das haben sie auch richtig gut gemacht. Was dann letztendlich dazu geführt hat, dass sie abgestürzt sind, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass das auch so ein bisschen ein Kopfproblem war. Ich glaube, die haben ihr letztes Rückrundenspiel mit 3-0 gegen den VfB Stuttgart gewonnen und spielen dann zum Anfang der Rückrunde 1-1 gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Ich glaube, die haben sich so im Kopf gedacht, was wollt ihr eigentlich, wir sind doch durch, uns kann doch nichts mehr passieren. Dass vielleicht sich da so psychologisch ein bisschen was im Kopf festgesetzt hat und ging es halt immer so weiter, immer so weiter und dann hast du halt kein Spiel mehr gewonnen, hast maximal unentschieden gespielt und bist immer weiter runtergerutscht und plötzlich wurde es dann eng und dann hast du den Schalter nicht mehr umgelegt bekommen.
Man muss ehrlich sagen, wenn man sich mal auf die Tabellenplatzkurve, wenn man mal draufschaut von den Würzburger Kickers, das sieht so ein bisschen so aus wie die VW-Aktie nach Bekanntgabe von Ingle Gate. Also wirklich unfassbar eingebrochen und wie wir jetzt auch schon mehrfach gesagt haben, bombig gestartet und dann am Anfang, ich glaube Platz 2 war das Höchste am fünften Spieltag und dann geht es irgendwie nur noch bergab. Also das ist echt unfassbar, was da passiert ist. Aber man fragt sich auch, warum? Was ist der Grund?
Na gut, einer der Gründe war, dass du halt auch wirklich das Tor nicht mehr getroffen hast. Die haben in der Hinrunde, waren sie Tabellen 6. mit 22 Toren, 27 Punkten. Rückrunde Tabellen 18. mit 10 geschossenen Toren. In 17 Spielen 10 Tore zu schießen, das ist ein Absteiger.
Ja, wie kann man denn eigentlich, erklär mir mal, wie das funktioniert, wie kann man in der gesamten Rückrunde kein Spiel gewinnen? Gab es das schon mal, dass jemand so eine schlechte Rückrunde gespielt hat?
Ey Leute, das fragt ihr den Typen, der sagt, er hat keine 2.
Liga Expertise. Ja, ist doch scheißegal, ob das jetzt in der 1. oder 2.
Ich kenne einen Verein, der hat in der Vorrunde kein Spiel gewonnen.
Ja, ich glaube, das haben alle gecheckt. Wie soll man da jetzt darauf reagieren, ohne das dann nochmal reinzuwirken, Stefan? Das ist so schwierig.
Ich bin da hart im Nehmen.
Der musste ja sein. Ja, also total krass auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, Hollerbach hat dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr Lösungen gefunden. Ist mir aber auch fast so einfach. Ich meine, Würzburg hat halt auch ganz, ganz oft kurz vor Schluss noch Führungen hergegeben. Also kein Team hat mehr Tore gefangen in den letzten 15 Spielminuten. 16 Gegentreffer zwischen der 76. und der 90. Spielminute. Könnte man jetzt auch ein Fitness-Thema aufmachen, dafür bin ich aber zu weit weg. Ehrlich gesagt, dafür habe ich zu wenig Spiele gesehen. Weiß nicht, ob es damit zusammenhängt. Vielleicht auch einfach nur Kopfproblem. Und dann hast du das ja häufig. Dann verstetigt sich das, weil die dann ganz oft bei einer knappen Führung, dann geht das in dir der Zeiger, dreht seine Runde und auf einmal bricht die 76. Minute an und plötzlich macht sich Panik breit. Und das wird nach hinten raus immer schlimmer. Anders ist es ja, glaube ich, beim KSC, der sich auch in die dritte Liga verabschiedet. So ein bisschen auch mit Ansage, zumindest wenn man mit KSC-Fans gesprochen hat und einer auch vollkommen irren Saison, Sebastian.
Ja, also ein bisschen mit Ansage auch klar. Wenn man sich da mal anschaut, da war die höchste Platzierung Platz 12. Ansonsten immer unten drin gewesen und dann wirklich, sagen wir, klanglos als Letzte abgestiegen. Es ist aber auch immer interessant, finde ich, so diesen Absturz solcher Mannschaften zu sehen, wenn man sich mal überlegt, dass es noch nicht so lange her ist, dass der KSC in der Relegation gegen den HSV um den Aufstieg in die 1. Liga gespielt hat. Und wir jetzt darüber sprechen, dass der KSC im kommenden Jahr in der 3. Liga an den Start geht. Das ist ja irgendwie ein Phänomen, was immer öfter mal passiert, dass Mannschaften eine total starke Saison spielen. Und dann, klar, wenn es dann da irgendwie ein, zwei Spieler gibt, die besonders rausstechen werden, die dann meistens von höherklassigen Vereinen gekauft, aber woran das liegt, dass Mannschaften so krass abstürzen können. Es ist auch nicht das erste Mal, dass der KSC in die dritte Liga absteigt. Man könnte jetzt sagen, als jemand, der aus KSL kommt, würde man es dem KSC gönnen, aber ich bin eigentlich eher der Meinung, ich möchte auch, dass Vereine, die man vielleicht nicht so gerne mag, weiter drin bleiben, weil das, was den Fußball ausmacht, sind eben diese Spiele und auch diese Derbies. Und ich glaube, auch die Bayern-Fans würden irgendwann ganz gerne mal wieder gegen 60 spielen. Statt zuzuschauen, wie dieser Verein zugrunde geht. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Als Mirko Slomka verpflichtet worden ist als Trainer, dachte ich noch, krass, wie haben sie das jetzt geschafft? Weil ich gehöre jetzt auch nicht zu denen, die sagen, von vornherein gesagt haben, Mirko Slomka ist jetzt nicht der beste Trainer. Aber ich dachte schon, okay, für einen KSC ist Mirko Slomka schon eine Hausnummer. Aber irgendwie hat das überhaupt nicht gepasst. Also von Anfang an überhaupt gar nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, beim KSC muss man auch gerade, wenn man die Relegation gegen den HSV noch in die Betrachtung mit einzieht, schon viel über die Trainer sprechen. Kauchinski ging zur Ingolstadt und damit ist halt die Konstante der letzten Jahre gegangen. Der war von 2012 bis 2016 Trainer, da hat einen eigenen Spielstil aufgebaut, hat eine Mannschaft formiert, die dazu auch gepasst hat. Kauchinski ging, Thomas Oral kam und es war nicht von all zu viel Erfolg gekrönt. Und dann kommt Mirko Slomka noch als zweiter Versuch, wo ich mir auch ehrlich gesagt, als er dort anfing, habe ich mir auch gedacht, krass, dass er sich das antut. Und jetzt, als er dann entlassen wurde und Marc-Patrick Meister übernommen hat, dachte ich mir, ja krass, dass sich der KSC Slomka angetan hat. Also sein Image hat jetzt nicht gerade einen Aufschwung erlebt durch dieses Engagement beim KSC. Aber ich glaube, das ist schon echt die wesentliche Komponente des Sotas. Da ist halt der Relegationsmacher Kowczynski weggefallen, der wirklich den KSC in ruhigere Fahrwasser gebracht hat. Ich meine, der hat 158 Spiele als Coach gemacht. Und dann hat man quasi es nicht geschafft, diesen Verlust vor allem aufzufangen.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass das der Bruch war in Karlsruhe. Das mit dem Weggang von Kowczynski, das war ja auch in diesem Trainer-Kausel, das sich da gedreht hat, ist da ein bisschen... Beim KSC hat sich das ja niedergeschlagen. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie Thomas Ohrheil geholt haben, weil was ich so in der Vorsaison von FSV Frankfurt-Fans gehört habe, die waren alle nicht begeistert von Ohrheil. Er ist ja glaube ich auch abgestiegen mit dem FSV Frankfurt. Weiß ich nicht, warum er da diese falsche Entscheidung getroffen hat, oder warum er sich da für Thomas Ohrheil entschieden hat. Kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, weil insgesamt war es natürlich nicht nur der Trainer, wenn man sich da die gesamte Saison anschaut, wenn man bloß 25 Punkte holt, nur 5 Mal gewinnt, Torverhältnis von minus 29, glaube ich, dann hat man ja auch auf dem Platz einen Fehler gemacht.
Du unterstellst ja dem KSC, dass die, oder anders formuliert, weil du fragst, warum haben sie den Trainer geholt? Dann müsstest du ja einen Verein wie man es haben, der wirklich einen Benchmark macht. Welche Trainer sind auf dem Markt, welcher passt zu uns, welche Kernkompetenzen hatte der vorherige Trainer, die wir gerne beibehalten wollen. Ich glaube, es ist nicht so einfach, einen Trainer zu suchen, der dann passt. Dann nimmst du vielleicht auch das, was auf dem Markt ist. Oder vielleicht, weil du den Berater kennst, oder, oder, oder. Ich glaube, dass Trainerentscheidungen bei vielen Vereinen mehr so ein Bauchgefühl sind, oder weil man sich kennt, oder sonstwie, oder weil der Berater eine Spielart, die man haben möchte, was weiß ich, was es da für Möglichkeiten gibt. Aber dass man sich hinsetzt und dann wirklich ganz klar ein Anfassungsprofil erstellt und definiert und sagt, okay, den nehmen wir und ich ziehe jetzt hier den Vergleich zur Wirtschaft und den Headhunter drauf ansetzt und sage so, jetzt liefern wir mal alles so ein. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das beim KSC passiert, oder bei vielen, vielen anderen Vereinen auch nicht.
Aber sollte doch eigentlich, meine Sachung.
Ja, logisch sollte das. Ich glaube es hätte nur nicht.
Also wie bei uns jetzt mit Alois Schwarz, da musste man sagen, hey, klar, man hat das Portfolio sich angesehen, man hat geguckt, was man wollte und die meisten Parameter haben gepasst. Deswegen hat man sich für Alois Schwarz entschieden. Muss nicht heißen, dass es dann gleich funktioniert, aber zumindest sollte man in die Richtung handeln, wenn man sich einen neuen Trainer holen will.
Sollte man schon, aber du musst ja auch dann schauen, was für ein Budget du hast für den Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Und wahrscheinlich musst du natürlich, wenn ein Trainer so lange da ist, die Aufgaben dritteln, weil du nicht nur einen holen musst, der auf dem Trainingsplatz steht und die Taktik vorgibt, sondern wenn du so lange Zeit Chef-Trainer in einem Verein bist, hast du wahrscheinlich viel mehr Sportdirektor-Aufgaben an dich gerissen, als man es vermuten würde beim Chef-Trainer.
Ja, und man kann halt auch mal einfach daneben liegen. Ich meine, Fehler passieren in allen Bereichen des Lebens. Das Problem ist halt nur bei solchen Vereinen, die einfach andere Mittel haben und auch eine andere Basis, auf der sie stehen, können halt Fehler auch oder Missentscheidungen, Fehlentscheidungen sehr schnell fatal sein. Und dann steigst du eben sang- und klanglos mit 27 geschossenen Toren, nur 5 Siegen in 34 Spielen, steigst du mal wieder in die dritte Liga ab. Und dann ist das eben einfach so.
Aber ihnen geht es immer noch besser als 68 Menschen.
Genau, und da muss man ja fast den 60ern dankbar sein. Und ja auch besser als vielen anderen Vereinen. Schaut euch FSV Frankfurt an, schaut euch Alemannia Aachen an zum Beispiel. Über 60 reden alle, über Aachen kaum jemand. Zweite Insolvenz jetzt schon. Also es gibt immer noch mal Vereine, denen es noch schlechter geht. Das, liebe KSC-Fans, nehmt das mit diesen letzten Worten von mir. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt, dass wir jetzt hier über alle 18 Vereine tatsächlich der 2. Liga sprechen konnten. Ich hoffe, wir sind den Erwartungshaltungen der Hörerinnen und Hörer gerecht geworden. Ihr habt meine voll und sogar übererfüllt. Ich danke euch dreien, zum einen Sebastian Zobel, Journalist und FCK-Experte beim SWR, bei twitter.ed, Twitter redo.
Ich hoffe, wir haben dein Interesse an der 2. Liga auch etwas größer werden lassen.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt habt ihr mir den Eindruck vermittelt, ich muss mir nur zweimal im Jahr einfach kompetente Leute einladen, dann muss ich mir den Scheiß nicht anschauen. Danke dafür. Außerdem herzlichen Dank an Stefan Helmer von Clubfans United, auch als at Clubfans United bei Twitter sehr aktiv. Danke dir Stefan, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne.
Und danke Enzo von 390 at LL Curly bei Twitter. Wir werden uns, denke ich, in der 1. Liga auch nochmal hören. Danke, dass du dir deine Premiere gegeben hast, Enzo. Und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke fürs Zuhören. Morgen solltet ihr das hier noch am Samstag des Champions League Finals hören, erscheint am Pfingstsonntag der Rasenfunk Royal zur 1. Liga. Das werden auch nochmal knackige, ja so roundabout 19 Stunden. Das heißt, hört das hier schnell weg. Wenn ihr das hier jetzt hört, habt ihr alles richtig gemacht. Und in dem Sinne wünsche ich euch eine schöne Sommerpause und mal gucken, wie viele Zweitligathemen ich im Rasenfunk noch behandeln kann. Es ist alles eine Frage der Zeit. Macht's gut, liebe Hörer, folgt uns auf Facebook, Twitter, YouTube und ihr könnt mir bei Snapchat beim Rasenfunk über die Schulter schauen. Ich hoffe allerdings in den nächsten Wochen nicht ganz so viel wie in den letzten Tagen. Macht's gut, Hörer, liebe Hörer und bis bald.
Das war die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossene Funk-Eihe.